baum grand privilège aujourd'hui de
recevoir jean marc jancovici monsieur
énergie
bienvenue en suisse bonjour bonjour
alors si certaines voix plus réducteur
de t'appeler mister énergie pour moi
c'est un peu un an third alerte
tu es aussi cofondateur de carbone 4
président du shift project c'est
d'ailleurs grâce à eux que tu ici je les
remercie notamment françois il se
reconnaîtra et puis tu es aussi maître
d'enseignement je rate peut-être
certaines choses allaient complète pour
moi je fais partie de la de la création
de notre cher président emmanuel macron
qui créent tous les six mois un nouveau
comité alors moi je suis dans la fournée
du haut conseil pour le climat donc je
suis membre du haut conseil pour le
climat en france c'est anne qui est un
organisme qui est censé donner un avis
enfin qu ils pas censés qui donne un
avis sur la façon dont la france
respecte ou pas les engagements qu'elle
s'est donnée sur la baisse des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mais déjà on
fait un beau cv alors j'aurais fait si
c'est pas moi je réfléchisse et aux
questions que je posais et puis comme ça
quand même fait une craque et de
conférences de vidéos et autres pour
être novateur ça va être un peu
compliqué mais je vais les pâtisseries
attitude de via ferrata gendarmes je
vais commencer par la fin avec toi
normalement deux m'ont toujours la
question qu'est-ce qui t'anime qu'elle
était source de motivation pour toi son
mauvais jeu de mots tus carbure à quoi
pour faire tout ce que tu fais comme
tout le monde je mange trois fois par
jour j'essaie de dormir de temps en
temps
j'ai besoin d'un peu de soutien de la
part de proches n'ont alors ce qui
m'anime c'est que je fais pas exception
ce beaucoup de gens dont on considère
entre eux avec les canons moderne entre
guillemets ça marche pour eux c'est
comme un jour j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à un sujet et il se trouve
que ça a rencontré l'intérêt de plein
d'autres gens donc quand il ya vingt ans
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
question du changement climatique
c'était un intérêt entre guillemets
égoïste je me suis pas posé la question
à l'époque de savoir si ça allait servir
l'humanité une fraction de l'humanité
les gens qui regardent squeezebox ou pas
je ne sais pas du tout où la manière
dont ça s'est déclenchée j'avais juste
c'était juste ça c'est un truc je
n'arrivais pas à comprendre et donc je
me suis dit je vais essayer de
comprendre
une fois que j'ai compris je suis quand
même intéressant d'arriver à comprendre
ce truc là je vais essayer de faire en
sorte que d'autres comprennent et en
fait mon intérêt pour la chose est né
comme ça et la première responsabilité
si je puis dire comme ça qui a été la
mienne est qui et qui m'a fait commencé
j'ai envie de dire à fatick qui a fait
que le changement climatique a commencé
à occuper une partie significative de
meilleur éveillé c'est que je suis
devenu l'animateur du groupe
environnement de mon association
d'anciens élèves à luminy et et j'ai
organisé une série de conférences sur la
question du changement climatique parce
que je me suis dit moi j'y comprends
rien pour le mans qui n'y comprennent
rien moi ça m'intéresse de comprendre
que probablement aussi c'est comme ça
que j'ai mis le pied à l'étrier
ensuite je me suis dit
je connaissais déjà le monde des
entreprises à l'époque que j'étais
consultant indépendant je me suis dit
peut-être qu'il ya manière d'en amener
certaines à réfléchir sur la façon dont
elles peuvent s'inscrire dans ce
problème et donc j'ai travaillé sur une
la mise au point d'une méthode qui
s'appelle le bilan carbone et qui a
donné lieu en gros à la norme actuelle
sur la comptabilité carbone et au moment
où j'ai fait ça je me suis pas dit je
vais devenir célèbre maintenant je me
suis dit qu'il y avait un problème à
résoudre je fais l'ingénieur de base
bête et méchant j'ai envie de dire il ya
un problème à résoudre pour que ce rêve
est intéressant je vais essayer de le
résoudre
je me suis pas posé plus la question que
ça et ça n'est qu'au fil du temps que je
me suis rendu compte que j'avais mis le
doigt sur un problème qui allait croître
et embellir qui allait susciter
l'intérêt d'un nombre croissant de gens
donc je pourrais dire d'une certaine
manière j'ai pas fait exprès de réussir
c'est pas ça qui m'a motivé au début
c'était vraiment que j'étais face à un
truc qui m'intéressait et j'avais juste
envie de bien comprendre voire
éventuellement de commencer à essayer
d'en vivre et de proposer autour de moi
des choses qui étaient utiles pour la
compréhension ce problème là quand j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à l'énergie ce
qui a été plus tard après le changement
climatique donc chronologiquement j'ai
d'abord regardé le changement climatique
ensuite je me suis intéressé au sujet
d'énergie alors à ce moment-là j'ai j'ai
avancé sur deux points qui était le les
questions autour de l'approvisionnement
pétrolier encore plus tard j'ai fini par
comprendre ce qu'était vraiment
l'énergie dans le fonctionnement du
moule moderne c'est-à-dire la mise ouvre
c'est à dire exactement la
transformation est en fait en termes
très pratique
le fait de pouvoir se joindre des
machines c'est mais j'ai compris ça tard
c'était pas c'était pas comme ça que
j'ai au début je suis rentré dans
l'énergie comme tout un chacun en disant
l'énergie c'est un machin qui s'achètent
c'est du pétrole à la pompe et ses
points quoi bon et c'est aussi à ce
moment là à ce moment là que je suis
rentré dans un débat qui est un débat
très chaud sans mauvais jeu de mots en
france qui la question du nucléaire
mais je me suis intéressé à cette
matière bien après m'être intéressé à la
fois aux changements climatiques et à
ses conséquences j'ai envie de dire
voilà donc j'ai donc une large partie de
ce que je suis devenu aujourd'hui ici
dantec
on considère que c'était que c'est un
marqueur de réussite je le dois à la
chance et au hasard plus exactement
totalement au hasard de voir le choisit
sujet exact de d'être tombés en travers
de ce sujet ça aurait aussi bien pu ne
pas m'arriver du tout de mon existence
et je pense soit dit en passant que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
aujourd'hui ils sont sous les feux des
projecteurs parce qu'on considère qu'ils
ont un parcours qui s'appelle réussite
en fait ils doivent une bonne partie de
ce parcours à la chance aussi parce
qu'il ya tellement d'impondérables dans
la vie que favori il se trouve que j'ai
encore une fois ça m'a ramené là dessus
mais ça aurait pu être autre chose
- bien que les scientifiques qui croient
à la chance personnellement j'y crois
pas trop ça se provoque
c'est à dire que en fait il ya des gens
qui ont des opportunités et qui
n'arrivent pas à s'en saisir
mais il ya aussi énormément de gens qui
voudraient se saisir des opportunités
qui n'ont jamais enfin je veux dire
cesser
il faut les deux ça c'était quand même
donc du coup les premiers d'intérêt que
tu as eue pour fin des années 90 on va
dire à 30 ans quand même deux cars
étaient sympas j'approche de 40 hockey à
ce moment-là j'approche de 49 de tim
questions qui pourraient être intéressés
quelles sont les principales clés de
compréhension les choses qui ont changé
dans ces 30 dernières années
c'est à dire les grosses fausse croyance
que tu que tu avais 20 d urée qu'un
moment les les choses tu dis ah bah ça
non j'aurais cru le contraire avant sur
le sujet que je traite pas grand chose a
dit autrement s'il ya un domaine dans ce
que je traite c'est que je suis beaucoup
revenu sur la possibilité de traiter le
problème par le signal prix est ce qu'on
appelle la taxe carbone là dessus j'ai
évolué mais c'est pas sur la
compréhension du problème à traiter
c'est sur la façon de le traiter sur la
compréhension du problème à traiter il
n'y a pas tellement de domaines il ya
pas tellement de choses sur lequel je me
suis dit j'avais compris de travers et
là maintenant c'est pas ce que s'est
passé parce que je crois que tu parles
du signal prix tu veux dire j'ai vu une
conférence d'hier a si longtemps où tu
disais tu pensais qu'à une corrélation
entre la rareté et le prix de la non
c'est pas ça parce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent si on a un problème avec les
énergies fossiles il faut monter le prix
des énergies fossiles
oualalou la société s'adapte et en
consomment moins et alors je restais
faire sens exactement alors sa part sfr
sens peut-être qu on en discutera plus
tard je me suis rien de celui de
maintenant je nomme comme tu le sens
parce que c'est un sujet mais disons que
j'ai beaucoup nuancer ce propos là c'est
dire que je crois toujours que c'est
utile mais je crois maintenant que c'est
10 % de la solution alors qu'avant
j'étais plus près de penser que c'était
50 un ordre de priorité par exemple mais
sinon sur le
alors là où j'aime à penser à évoluer
dans le mauvais sens j'ai envie de dire
c'est que je pense qu'au début de la
compréhension de ce problème
j'étais plus optimiste que maintenant
sur le temps qui nous reste pour éviter
à la situation de devenir totalement
hors de contrôle
là je pense que malheureusement on n'en
est plus très loin je me rappelle qu'il
ya 10 ou 15 ans j'ai une amie qui avait
sorti un livre dans lequel elle date tel
effondrement de 2030
moi j'avais été très frappé avant par un
travail qui absolument magistral et que
j'invite tous les tous les gens qui ont
le temps à consulter qui est un travail
qui a été fait par une équipe de
dynamicien des systèmes lui a mighty du
massachusetts institute of technology il
ya dans les années 60 et qui a donné
lieu en eau début des années 70 donc en
septembre 2 à la publication d'un livre
qui en anglais ça plaide adémistes groff
et qui a été mal traduits en français
mais et qui expliquait que dans un
univers fini les flux physiques ne
pouvait jamais croître indéfiniment et
que en particulier la production
économique qui est un flux physiques ne
pouvait pas croître indéfiniment mais
dans le travail de ces modélisateurs à
l'époque il disait c'est n'importe quoi
entre 2000 et 2100 qu'on va vraiment
avoir des emmerdements sérieux et quand
j'ai lu ce travail alors je sais pas si
c'est un des fers avec meetic ou je me
suis dit entre 2000 et 2005 et 2050 on a
encore un peu de temps mais je voyais un
horizon de temps restant
pour éviter les environnements qui était
qui était important et aujourd'hui j'ai
tendance à raccourcir les horizons de
temps c'est à dire que je pense que les
claques on commence à les prendre
maintenant et que malheureusement ça va
pas aller en s'améliorant et donc les
horizons de temps sont probablement plus
court que le lit les groseilles c'est
pour ça que je disais tout à l'heure un
peu lent third alerte parce que plus ton
temps et plus j'ai l'impression que tu
viens que des arguments et une force
fait assez virulent dans tes propos est
ce que tu cherches aussi une réaction
est ce que tu vois même santé inquiète
et puis tu commences et du coup a tapé
du poing où il faisait plus fort sur la
table alors la réponse est doublement
oui évidemment que je cherche une
réaction sinon je ne ferais pas ça
est-ce que je mon inquiétude augmente
oui alors c'est à la fois de
l'inquiétude et si je peux employer le
terme de l'énervement qui augmente non
de l'énervement qu'un jeu il ya un côté
énervé alors l'inquiétude oui parce que
plus le temps passe sans que il ya alors
je sais un peu décousu tout ça mais il
ya dans le domaine informatique
une petite règle qui est bien connu qui
est ce qui coûte 1 à corriger au moment
de la conception coûte 10 à corriger au
moment du développement sang au moment
du déploiement emile une fois que c'est
en services d'accor
donc il ya une prime au fait de corriger
le plus en amont possible les vision
erronée qui est qui est extrêmement
forte et depuis que j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à ce sujet on a fait
l'exact inverse dans un certain nombre
de pays dont le mien c'est à dire que on
a passé notre temps et notre argent ne
peut pas poser le problème à plat car on
a fait l'économie du moment où on pose
le problème à plat en disant c'est là
qu'il faut commencer par porter les
efforts et l'argent on a foncé tête
baissée sur des conneries alors on en
reparlera aussi
en france l'éolien et le solaire c'est
perdre son temps et son argent il ya des
trucs beaucoup plus important à faire et
donc ça c'est le sentiment d'urgence
j'ai envie de dire qu'il augmente parce
que rappaz d'extra valin et la deuxième
la deuxième chose qui augmente ses
l'énervement parce que il ya une phrase
que j'emploie parfois qui consiste à
dire personne mais un revolver sur la
tempe à quelqu'un quand ils se
présentent pour être député ministre au
président c'est pas une obligation
d'accord monsieur macron il n'est pas
devenu président parce qu'on l'a collé
un revolver sur la tempe en disant tu
fais ça ou je te flingue
ce qui veut dire qu'à partir du moment
où les gens ambitionne d'avoir ce genre
de responsabilité ils sont obligés ils
ont une obligation qui est celle de
faire les choses sérieusement et celle
de comment dire 'ne de ne pas faire les
dilettantes et ne pas faire les fumistes
c'est la théorie
mais pour pour arriver à se faire élire
en général ils ont dû déjà activé un peu
l'oreille mais on peut même dans ce
contexte là essayer de se garder un peu
de temps pour soi pour au moins pour soi
essayez de comprendre quels sont les
vrais problèmes à régler c'est à dire
qu'à un moment il faut il faut se il
faut passer un peu moins de temps à se
complaire dans la démagogie et un peu
plus de temps à comprendre le monde tel
qu'il est bon là c'est plutôt de
l'énervement
c'est à dire que je me dis part de moi
l'expression à un moment je me dis c'est
j'aurais quand même se [ __ ] de la
gueule du monde
c'est à dire que rien ne les empêche de
passer un peu de temps à essayer de
comprendre comment fonctionne le monde
rien ne les empêche de le faire leur
carry enfin il a une carrière à mener il
voit pas ils veulent faire avancer leur
carrière point îles tonga mais je pense
que c'est même pas comme ça je pense que
paradoxalement il augmente le risque de
finir à l'échafaud parce qu'il y aura
une armée populaire mais toute
l'histoire politique française récente
c'est sortez les sortants
c'est à dire que justement à un moment
il se retrouve trop en décalage avec les
attentes de la population
alors au début c'est tout beau tout beau
tout neuf
voilà honey moon et puis et puis tu
exactement et puis très rapidement cessé
ils se retrouvent en décalage
j'insiste je pense vraiment que
il ya un côté irresponsable dans le fait
quand on ambitionne la conduite des
affaires d'un pays de ne pas passer du
temps à se documenter sur quelque chose
qui est devenu un enjeu central dans la
conduite des affaires du pays
c'est comme c'est pas comme s'il n'était
pas au courant qu'il ya quelque chose ne
peuvent pas ne pas être au courant
voilà est ce que je dis et extrapolable
alors la suisse a fait pas partie mais
ce que je dis et extrapolable haut
fonctionnaire de la une par une large
partie des hauts fonctionnaires de la
commission et c'est aujourd'hui il y à
là par la partie qui m'énerve c'est
essentiellement celle là c'est l'acte
délibéré de ne pas prendre les 20 ou 30
heures que ça prend dans la vie d'un
individu de comprendre correctement pour
les maltraiter voilà parce qu'on parle
pas de centaines d'heures on parle de 20
ou 30 heures pour bien comprendre je
veux dire là je sors de le pfl ou en 25
minutes j'ai posé quelques bases
essentielles et je sais que les
étudiants qui ont complété sa part 10
heures ils auront l'essentiel ils n'ont
pas besoin d'en avoir un milliard de
bons et je suis très énervé par le fait
qu' une bonne partie des gens qui
prétendent faire des choses qui sont
utiles pour la dire collectif n'intègre
pas ça dans leur raisonnement simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pris le temps de
se documenter
voilà c'est le cas aussi pour l'élite
politique suisse à mon avis les
françaises et les prétoires lors plus
déconnectés mais je parle de ce que je
connais donc garderait d'avoir un avis
sur le livre politique suisse car je ne
connais pas je me lève plus que ce que
je dis est également extrapolable aux
dirigeants du monde économique
c'est pareil aucun dirigeant du monde
économique ne peuvent invoquer le
prétexte qu'il n'a pas le temps pour pas
je veux dire ils ont quand même le temps
de lire des bouquins et sait qu'il n'a
pas le temps de
de passer 20 heures à se documenter
correctement sur ce sujet alors là on a
une période un peu particulière de
l'humanité donc ce ce qu vide qu'on n'a
pas vu venir en tout cas pas sous cette
forme là est ce que c'est la
confirmation d'un monde malade ou
finalement l'espoir parce que on arrive
à changer très rapidement les habitudes
contrôler que les masques le confinement
et d'autres choses que ça soit pertinent
ou non montre que tout d'un coup on
arrive à déployer des moyens fenomeno
pardon pour modifier le status quo voilà
ça c'est un petit peu c'est un petit
panda 2 a laissé un peu les deux les
deux mon capitaine
le coc vide est illustratif dérégulation
qui vont nous tomber sur la figure sans
qu'on n'ait rien demandé si on ne régule
pas le système de nous mêmes alors je
reviens à ce travail absolument
extraordinaire de des mystery of ce que
disait la fin de la croissance s'était
traduit comme ça je crois alors ça a été
traduit par halte à la croissance en
français avec un point d'interrogation
enfin bon c'est s'était pas c'était pas
interrogatif dans ce titre anglais s'est
s'était pas halte c'était les limites
donc là du coup mais les français sont
pas très bons pour traduire pertinemment
les expressions anglaises on était pas
on n'est pas dans le coup d'essai là
dessus donc le point en venir à ce que à
ce que j étais là le coc bidasses est
illustratif d'un événement
externes non anticipée qui a un effet
qui lui est anticipable c'est à dire qu'
il va nous forcer à diminuer les flux
physiques qu'on met en oeuvre parce que
de fait on sait moins déplacés
l'industrie à moins tourner on a craché
un peu moins de co2 de la planète terre
ce que ce que disent les gens
d'autonomistes grosse c'est que sur une
planète qui ne changent pas de taille au
cours du temps et dont les ressources
n'augmente pas au cours du temps il n'y
a pas plus de minerai de cuivre
aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait il ya mille
ans c'est la même quantité
c'est l'autre qui disait faut être soit
fou économie cboe holdings ca boulding
qu'on prête cette citation alors je n'ai
pas réussi à trouver cette citation dans
les écrits de building par contre en
cherchant sur goulding a pas très
longtemps car goulding j'ai trouvé un
article qu'il a écrit quelques années
avant le travail de dynamique des
systèmes dont je viens de parler donc
dans les années 60 et dont le titre est
alors je sais pas si c'est exactement ça
sinon à un mot près c'est ça c'est dit
et comme un mix of the coming space ship
of et dans lequel building explique que
le pib qui est notre ami dans un monde
qu'on voit comme un fini devient à notre
ennemi dans un monde qu'on voit comme
signe c'est à dire que de considérer que
la terre est un vaisseau spatial s'est
d'ailleurs fini fait que la croissance
qui était une solution devient un
problème aux marques dans les années 60
remarquable certains ont compris ce qui
est remarquable aussi c'est que c'est
écrit là pour le coup le sujet de la
croissance a été longtemps sur le plan
académique un débat entre physicien
économistes c'est à dire que d'un côté
il ya des économistes qui disent qu'ils
manipulent des modèles dans lesquels à
aucun moment le modèle dit quand pib
arrivera sans 2353 milliards de dollars
il s'arrête
il n'y a pas ça alors que dans les
modèles physiques ya ça partout quand la
voiture dans laquelle il faut évidemment
pas monter arrive à 375 km heure elle va
pas plus vite les limites
voilà quand l'avion arrive à 800 kg et
dans lequel il faut pas remonter non
plus alors il va 800 km heure pas fier à
une limite ils s'arrêtent aux 860 j'en
sais rien
quand l'ascenseur arrive au dixième
étage les limites physiques qui sert à
lille ils peuvent aller plus loin mais
il avait compris mais n'implique pas le
découplage je crois en tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'ils arrivent à rétablir
justement fichiers justement mais sauf
que dans les modèles économiques ya
aucune limite en dur c'est à dire que le
ça n'existe pas parce que dans la
théorie ça n'existe pas hélas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que boulding dit ça ne
peut pas marcher comme ça donc en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'un
économiste lui-même pas un physicien dit
ma discipline
en fait va devoir revoir la façon dont
elles théorise sans son raisonnement
dans un monde qui est physiquement
limité
c'est ça qui est intéressant évidemment
j'avais rien produit comme effet je veux
dire on est resté avec l'économie fausse
qu'on manipule tous les jours mais c'est
quand même très intéressant donc pour en
revenir à locaux vides le nos amis du
alors on l'a souvent vulgariser comme
étant le rapport du club de rome parce
que je viens d'évoquer la les limites à
la croissance mais en fait c'est oui
c'est ça mais en fait ce n'est pas le
rapport du ces le rapport aux clubs
d'europe
c'est l'équipe de haïti duhamel 10 qui a
fait au club de rome un rapport en
disant voilà scientifiquement ce qu'il
faut comprendre donc donc l'équipe
meadows dit
au bout d'un moment le système se régule
de lui-même donc après la croissance
arrive la décroissance est donc le coc
vite pour moi il est représentatif du
type de régulation qu'on aura parce
qu'après on peut théoriser avec d'autres
d'autres moyens il y en a l'équation de
kaya par exemple dans mon secteur et
c'est le fait que si on ne régule pas de
nous mêmes des phénomènes externes qu'on
est évidemment pas capable de décrire la
vence mais on sait dans quelle catégorie
ils appartiennent réguleront soit
l'économie soit la population soit les
deux à la fois et donc en fait les les
grandes conséquences involontaires
désagréable que nous aurons à cause de
la finitude des ressources ou de la
finitude de l'environnement des
poubelles en gros changement climatique
étant dans la deuxième catégorie c'est
une poubelles qui débordent et bien
causeront des régulations d'aider des
pressions à la baisse soit de la
population soit de la production
économique par personne
le coc vide est un exemple timide parce
qu'il va pas beaucoup réguler la
population
il a fait aujourd'hui en france moins de
morts qu'une année de tabagie donc pour
le moment ça reste un non événement
suscite chez suicide chez les jeunes ces
quelques milliers de morts par an alors
après on peut savoir si quelques
milliers de suicide chez les jeunes
c'est plus ou moins dramatiques quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes de 80
ans fait pertinents alors moi je crois
en parlons tête de pipe
et ben non moi je crois qu'elle est
extrêmement pertinente parce que je
pense que ces problèmes posent la
question de l'équité entre générations
c'est à dire que sk au motif qu'il faut
préserver des gens qui sont de la
génération de mes parents
il faut empêcher des gens de ta
génération de vivre et je pense que
c'est pas du tout une question théorique
je pense que c'est une question centrale
est aujourd'hui un tableau un peu trop
le droit d'imposer ses bas moi je la
pose parce que je pense que c'est pas du
tout un débat trivial et je pense que la
réponse est pas du tout oui à l'évidence
il faut d'abord préserver les vieux
quand on a notre président qui dit à
skins tétanie c'est que les gens meurent
pas dans les ehpad
il ya un côté j'étais choqué des gens
qui vont écouter mais je pose quand même
une question est ce qu un ehpad
c'est un endroit où dont on et sortait
d'un ton essence et pardon ressorti en
meilleure santé qu'on y est entré non
c'est un endroit où on est censé mourir
un mouroir un ehpad c'est à ça que ça
sert empêcher les gens de mourir dans un
mouroir
il ya une forme alors qu'ils meurent le
plus longtemps possible on n'empêche pas
les gens de mourir dans un mouroir ils y
vont pour ça qu'ils vivent le plus
longtemps possible
oui mais oui pardon mais on n'empêche
pas les gens de bruit dans un endroit
je répète il ya un côté totalement
hypocrite
bon alors encore une fois que ça se
passe dans de bonnes conditions tard et
c'est ça se discute oui mais mais mais
donc le la manière dont on a dont on est
en train de gérer les problèmes en ce
moment c'est clairement un arbitrage en
faveur des vieux est en défaveur des
jeunes on a sacrifié un trimestre de
scolarité de plein d'élèves notamment
les élèves des milieux défavorisés parce
que allez donc télétravailler est
scolarisé les gamins quand vous êtes
dans un deux pièces de 40 mètres carrés
on en reparle quoi je veux dire les gens
les gens de 50 ans ont conclu les
enfants à la maison et au travail en
trouve ça génial
les gens de 35 ans de gamins en âge
primaire à la maison je sais pas ce que
je sais pas ce qu'a catastrophique
oui la scolarité a pas pu être normal
enfin je veux dire bon donc donc ce je
le redis on a alors peut-être que
c'était le truc à faire en tout cas le
résultat net de l'histoire c'est que on
a exercé une pression sur la jeune
génération ou détriment des lieux global
mans ce collage moyen du décès en france
étaient 80 noms sur pendant 80 1 en jeu
c'est à dire un an de moins que
l'espérance de vie donc le
voilà donc le co leaders représentatifs
en ce sens que c'est une disruption
qu'on n'a pas vu venir danser effet ça
reste très timide
c'est par rapport à ce qui nous attend
si on continue à traiter par dessus la
jambe
les sujets énergie et climat un petit
avertissement
oui j'ai un petit avec la quête oui
effectivement alors tu disais c'est des
bains jeunes plus anciens moi ça me fait
tout de suite penser à ce refus de la
mort d'une certaine manière sociale
débat conversation veut le repousser
leurs côtés le repousser mais on voit
que maintenant au niveau idéologique la
guéguerre elle se trouverait un peu
entre les décroissants et
transhumanistes toi tu es aussi beaucoup
dans le monde des universités des
enfants d'aider les lieux de la science
technique et j'entends souvent ce genre
de discours
dans ces lieux là que la science et la
technologie va dépasser d'une certaine
manière c'est limité mais c'est mes
limites là pardon
comment tu t'y prends pour en fait ce
débat c'est le débat entre le fatalisme
est là et le fait d'être persuadé qu'on
peut agir surtout c'est le débat entre
entre les deux quelque part alors quand
j'étais jeune il y avait déjà de la
médecine mais il y avait aussi une forme
de fatalisme face à la mort mais pas
face à toutes les morts il y avait un
fatalisme face à une mort qui était
qu'il était normal et même souhaitable
de mourir quand on était vieux donc il y
avait une expression quand j'étais jeune
qui s'appelait mourir de vieillesse
qu'on appelait soit dit en passant aussi
parfois mourir de sa belle mort
il y avait cette expression je me dis
toi tu ça te dit quelque chose
sa belle mort c'était mourir quand toi
et tes vieux donc non seulement ce n'est
pas illégitime de mourir quand on était
vieux mais c'est même ce qui était
souhaitable
d'accord on devenait vieux puits en bois
craque et puis voilà c'était ça qui
était bien alors mourir la guerre ce
n'est pas bien on était jeunes mourir
d'une maladie une saloperie quand on
avait 30 ans c'est pas bien mourir quand
on était une femme etc ont donné
naissance à un gamin c'était pas bien et
mourir quand on était un gamin et à un
an ce n'est pas bien mais par contre
pouvoir quand on est des vieux c'est
normalement aujourd'hui ça existe plus
la mort de vieillesse parce que toutes
les morts ou une cause technique et on
ne meurt plus de vieillesse meurt d'un
avc de par kingson de alzheimer de d'un
cancer pas griller toutes les morts en
cause technique des griffes du coc vide
et comme toutes les morts ont une cause
technique du coup il ya nécessairement
une solution puisque tout problème
technique à une solution technique donc
si le coeur méchant stick et ben on va
mettre un coeur artificiel si les
apporte son boucher ont les débauches
avec un petit coup de destop à wörth
toutes causes techniques et curable et
donc on est rentré dans notre rapport à
la mort dont l'expression la plus
aboutie et les transhumanistes dans
lequel avec des rustines technique
finalement on tient aussi longtemps que
voilà lors la question à laquelle ils
savent pas répondre c est ce qu on aura
assez de sudoku pour s'occuper
une fois qu'on est devenu immortel fini
par se faire chier enfin je sais pas si
elle perd son sens au bout d'un moment
on a tout vu tout entendu tout fait ou
etc mais bon voilà quoi
et puis par ailleurs il faut bien se
rappeler que dans l'évolution des
espèces la vie faire d'abord c'est la
vie c'est la mort s'est laissée là c'est
laisser la place à la génération qui
vient parce qu'il n'y a pas assez d
espace pour tout le monde et par
ailleurs c'est l'évolution sans nord pas
d'évolution g dire s'il y avait aussi
les espèces n'était pas mortelle sur
terre on ne serait pas là nous on serait
resté au stade des bactérie mortelle
donc le jeu pas en train de faire
l'apologie de la mort je pense mais je
suis juste en train de dire aujourd'hui
finalement le degré de fatalisme qui
était peut-être excessif dans un sens
est devenue excessive excessive dans ce
pourquoi il faut dire le balancier
peut-être allé trop loin de l'autre côté
et le transhumanisme aujourd'hui pour
moi il ému il est poussé par des gens
qui n'ont plus de problème donc c'est
des gens qui mangent à leur faim quand
pas de prime de fin de mois ils
s'emmerdent et donc il vise un maintien
pur je deviendrai pas immortels mais
c'est parce que tous les autres
problèmes sont réglés
bon et puis c'est très américain
c'est-à-dire ses traits issu d'un pays
no limits quoi c
voilà donc j'ai franchi telles limites
étaient limitées telles limites et elles
limitent la matière qu'est ce qui me
reste à cocher dans mons comme un jeu
vidéo c'est quoi le state qui manque
encore avec un vix et vie éternelle
tiens je vais cochez cette case là il ya
un côté très c'est marrant parce que
c'est un peu revenir à des rêves de
gosse
c'est alors où est ce que je me situe
dans le débat entre le progrès technique
et le fatalisme justement je suis
fataliste face aux lois de la physique
dit autrement la loi de conservation de
l'énergie je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
progrès technique qui peut la violer et
non seulement le problème technique ne
peut pas la violer mais c'est
précisément parce que ces lois sont
inviolables donc totalement prédictible
que le progrès technique peut exister
encore si l'électromagnétisme n'était
pas à la base de loi totalement
inviolable et rendant les choses
totalement prédictible j'aurais pas ce
micro devant la bouche en ce moment et
les gens qui regardent le signal qui va
leur parvenir ne pourrait pas regarder
le signal d'accord parce qu'il n'y
aurait pas de l'oie prévisible et donc
le système parce qu'ils voudraient et je
dirais blanc et on entendrait pâtisserie
donc le donc je suis totalement
fatalistes face aux limites qui sont
imposées par les lois de la physique
je suis raisonnablement fataliste sur le
câblage de la cervelle humaine c'est à
dire que je pense que la façon dont
notre cervelle est organisée est un truc
qui ne se change pas par un claquement
de doigts et dizaines de millions
d'années d'évolution nous ont construit
notre cervelle en nous collant un cortex
par dessus le siège de nos désirs et
compliqué
de changer ça il ya une très belle
citation je crois qu'on attribue aussi
n'osa puis nous avons qu'il dit que nous
ne sommes pas des animaux rationnelle
mais nous exécutons rationnellement nos
désirs
je suis fataliste face à ça d'accord est
en fait les transhumanistes il exécute
rationnellement leurs désirs
ils sont pas rationnels non pas plus que
moi du reste un je suis pas non plus
rationnelle donc la question qui m'a
posé en entrée qui est pourquoi tu fais
ce que tu fais pas parce que j'en ai eu
le désir et pourquoi est-ce que j'ai
débat c'est parce que c'était comme ça
là donc je suis fataliste là dessus
aussi et donc plus généralement je suis
fataliste sur un certain nombre
d'éléments qui dépendent pas ou
tellement peu de nous à des échelles de
temps qui sont celles de l'action que je
les prends comme des données d'entrée du
problème après je crois au progrès à
condition de correctement le définir
c'est à dire que le progrès pour moi
c'est l'avancée vers un objectif qu'on
considère comme souhaitable
le progrès technique stricto sensu n'est
pas nécessaire ne correspond pas
nécessairement à cette définition
quand les nazis ont mis au point les
chambres à gaz et que le zyklon b pas
complètement sûr que c'est un pôle
technique c'était beaucoup plus efficace
de gaz et les gens en masse cette
manière que autrement pas complètement
sûr que je si j'enlève technique je mets
toujours progresser
je dois pouvoir se discuter
de même que alors désolé d'être un peu
taquin vis-à-vis de nos amis suisses
mais enfin les avocats fiscalistes
suisse qui il fut un temps faisait les
beaux jours de leurs clients en leur
permettant d'échapper au fisc de leur
pays
c'était assurément du progrès technique
dans une part complètement sûr que
j'appelle ça du progrès non plus donc
la question du progrès elle elle et
c'est compliqué de la dissocier de la
crise parce qu'on a tendance à assimiler
progrès en progrès technique donc dès
qu'on met au point un truc nouveau on
considère finalement bien dit c'est bon
et aujourd'hui malheureusement on manque
totalement de recul sur cette
distinction on a en france en ce moment
un débat qui émergent sur le déploiement
des réseaux télécoms de nouvelle
génération la 5g qui est en train suisse
aussi qui est en train de monter assez
fort alors notre président vient de se
mettre au niveau de trump macron
je sais pas si en suisse vous avez
entendu sa saillie qui l'a fait sur les
amish et la lampe à huile
oui mais c'est vraiment du niveau si
j'ai pas ce que je veux je fais pipi par
terre allemande le dire c'est puéril
comme rédaction à moins que ce soit très
savamment calculée ou quelqu'un c'est
inquiétant parce que ça veut dire qu'ils
traquent sur les terres populiste pour
son électorat mais dans un cas comme
dans l'autre ça oui dans un cas comme
dans l'autre c'est inquiétant c'est ou
bien c'était sincère et c'est inquiétant
ou bien c'est calculé et c'est prêt de
quelque part encore plus inquiétant mais
on est totalement dans l'amour et
gadgets c'est à dire qu'on se pose pas
la question de savoir si c'est ça
correspond à la définition du progrès
que j'ai donné c'est à dire se
rapprocher d'un objectif considéré comme
souhaitable et à ce moment il faut
savoir ce qui est considéré comme
souhaitable c'est juste ces nouveaux
donc c'est bien on va pas chercher plus
loin
donc je crois que dans le contexte dans
lequel nous sommes où on pourra pas
courir tous les chevaux à la fois on est
obligé de se poser la question de savoir
dans quel ordre on met nos priorités et
du coup dans quel ordre mais nos
renoncements clair à quoi ce soit c'est
plus facile de renoncer ce qui va
falloir confiance et oubliez donc est-ce
que je renonce à l'espoir pour l'avenir
pour les jeunes est ma priorité c'est de
pouvoir continuer demain matin à voir la
vidéo qu'ils téléchargent en 10 secondes
ou et bien est-ce que j'arbitre d'une
façon différente et c'est ça dont on en
revient à la question du départ qui
était à quel moment est ce qu'on arrive
à faire passer l'information sur le
problème à traiter parce que tout part
de là et tant qu'on n'a pas réussi à
partager cette information là c'est très
très difficile d'avoir un débat apaisé
savoir un débat tout court parce qu'on
parle pas de la même chose il exactement
alors de rentrer alors là avec le
quotidien on a très rapidement et pour
le mieux à mon pardon j'ai pas répondu à
la question sur l'opportunité et oui
alors le coc vide est une opportunité
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que
finalement on était resté vivant alors
que du jour au lendemain on a arrêté de
se déplacer en bagnole pour une bonne
partie des gens on arrivait d'aller au
bureau d'autres ont carrément arrêter de
travailler tout court et dans cette
affaire alors la société s'est pas
effondré donc bon alors il ya des gens
qui vont qui vont quand même en subir
des conséquences de manière violente
il ya en france sept cent mille chômeurs
de plus et je pense que c'est que le
début
donc c'est je suis pas en train de dire
que ça s'est fait
sans son tour la saucisse en coût pour
la société et sans souffrance
par contre pour tous les gens donc sept
cent mille personnes ça fait 1 % de la
population française donc pour les 99%
restants ils sont quand même passés à
travers cet épisode en changeant
significativement ce qu'il faisait avant
ils en sont pas morts et même non
seulement ils ne sont pas morts mais ça
ne changera pas grand chose à leur
sécurité pour l'avenir 1% pour que ça
change dramatiquement et donc on peut
aussi être optimiste et voit les 99%
restants en disant quand même c'est
possible et si on arrivait à faire des
changements s'approchant de ça en ayant
pas les 1% qui perdent leur job c'est
encore mieux donc ça c'est c'est ça la
partie optimiste c'est à dire qu'on se
rend compte en fait que
il ya des moments où on est capable de
réorienter alors moi je le savais déjà
il ya un précédent célèbre dans
l'histoire mais c'est un précédent
célèbre en période de croissance ce qui
est un peu différent qui est la
reconversion de l'économie américaine
pendant la dernière guerre mondiale
c'est quand même hallucinant je veux
dire il fabriquait des bagnoles au bout
de trois ans il fabrique plus une
bannière failli fabrique une bagnole et
au bout de trois ans il fabrique que des
avions et des bateaux il en fait ils ont
totalement il ya 30 ou 40% du pib
américain qui a été réorientée en trois
ans donc j'ai coutume de dire que face
aux problèmes qui sont les miens si on
se donnait les moyens on pourrait le
faire alors c'est ça sa part entre et
peut-être de l'économie guerre cela
étant le coc vide ça a été de l'économie
d'hyères il ya tout d'un coup on a
restreint les libertés réorienter la
manière de produire ces de la
planification et on n'en est pas très
loin
on a rationné certains trucs par exemple
accès à l'espace public étaient
rationnés une heure par jour pas plus
pour faire pisser de chiens j'ai pas
quoi va donc on a on a on a on a
instantanément mis en place n'est pas
truqué des mesures drastiques que les
gens ou acceptés dont ils sont
accommodés alors certaines sont vraiment
pas drôle mais mais ça induit des
changements
je le vois par exemple dans la mobilité
quotidienne dans les grandes
agglomérations alors malheureusement la
bagnole ça s'est déplacé pas de la bonne
façon pour moi puisque en gros les
transports en commun sont moins remplies
et les gens font plus de vélos la
bagnole est revenu au niveau de
saturation ou l'aider à laon est
évidemment j'aurais préféré que ce soit
moins de bagnols autant de transport en
commun et plus de vélos sais pas ce qui
s'est passé pour le mes est un peu plus
de vélo quand même puis ils ont passé un
petit peu des pistes partout mais je
pense que ça a malheureusement pas
essentiellement pris sur les
automobilisme je pense que ça a
essentiellement pris sur les gens dès
qu'ils étaient dans les transports
publics parce que oui ils sont tétanisés
à l'idée
ils pensent qu'ils vont mourir dans la
semaine si lien entre un élément que tu
donnes que j'aime beaucoup en termes de
vulgarisation c'est de se dire ben en
terme économique et de réduction du co2
il faudrait un kobe 2 par année mais
l'un sur l'autre
donc chaque année il faudra faire les
mêmes efforts si on veut prétendre
finalement arrivée vous regardez les
efforts qu'on a déjà fait et faire
l'équivalent en plus oui mais le
problème c'est que là enfin moi qui
faisais de la politique pendant pas mal
d'années à chaque fois qu'on vous on
avait des idées soit pour protéger le
climat ou soit sociale c'était on n'a
pas assez d'argent pour ça on n'a pas
assez d'argent
là il convient depuis on a eu assez
d'argent alors la question de l'argent a
explosé alors oui on va mettre les lions
là en suisse on a sauvé suisse air et
puis les on a balancé l'argent sans en
parler mais moi je suis assez certain
que cette question financière
dès que ce sera un petit peu calmé tout
ça elle va revenir mais tellement avec
force que on va plus entendre aucun
aucun développement aucun débat sur le
sur le changement climatique et
l'énergie
peut-être 1,30 mais comment tu vois la
chose je pense que ça va prendre après
parce que maintenant il va y avoir il va
y avoir un problème économique ça n'a
pas tourné ça va faire réagir parce
qu'il faut dire en suisse les principaux
partis c'est parti de droite est parti
soit bourgeois soit les partis qui sont
les grands patrons début décès mais de
l'autre partie droite c'est quoi c'est
le plr c'est parti libéral radical
et puis le pdc il perd teaparty simple
plutôt centriste mais de droite encore
pleinement
partie chrétien enfin il va enlever le
mot chrétien je crois qu'ils sont en
train de discuter pour l'enlever et la
gauche tant que les verts et les
socialistes en sont minoritaires
d'accord je suis tout à fait d'accord
tout d'un coup l'argent n'a pu été le
problème alors sauf que avant il y avait
eu un autre épisode où l'argent n'a pu
été le problème c'est 2008 1 c'est quand
il a fallu sauver les banques un
précédent bilan n'est pas non plus un
problème qu'il faut le trouver
et pour reprendre l'exemple que j'ai
donnée delà de la seconde guerre
mondiale à ce moment là l'argent n'a pas
été un problème non plus dire que post
seconde guerre mondiale et une explosion
de l'endettement
alors il faut que ans après on a basculé
dans les trente glorieuses et que la
croissance a permis de rembourser
l'endettement mais aussi pendant la
guerre on s'est endettée et à tire
larigot 1 notamment les états européens
et puis après les etats-unis ont fait de
la remise de dette contre le faim je le
plan marshall a été une grande opération
de d'achat à crédit
donc le iliad hockey les précédents la
question c'est est-ce qu'avec les
histoires d'énergie et de climat on va
en arriver au stade où on est comme donc
pour le sauvetage des banques ou le coc
vite c'est à dire que l'argent n'est
plus le sujet c'est ce que j'espère
qu'est ce que ça nous prendra d'en
arriver là des baffes
parce que malheureusement on est ainsi
câblée que alors peut-être que ce qui
est en train de se passer en ce moment
avec l'australie qui crament puis la
sibérie qui crament puis les forêts
françaises qui crèvent puis la
californie qui crament puis le brésil
qui crament puis soudan qui est inondé
et puis et c'est peut-être que ça va un
peu nous calmer je ne sais pas
reste loin ça commence à se rapprocher
parce qu'en français par exemple les
forêts crève et alors il ya un certain
nombre de la sécheresse augmente alors
il ya quand même beaucoup de dirigeants
en france qui ont trois arbres soient
dans leur jardin parce qu'ils vivent
dans les grandes maisons et des grands
jardins parce que c'est là où vivent les
gens aisés soient ils ont inclus soit
ils vivent dans des soyeux un bout de
forêt où la famille à un bout de forêt
où ils vont chasser en solo du jeu
pourquoi donc
non mais il ya un rapport à la forêt ou
à l'arbre
qui est qui et qui existe et alors ça ça
leur fout un peu la trouille
parce que il voit là les conséquences
sont déjà là donc le puits le monde
français a toujours été un peu sensible
à la souffrance des agriculteurs on a
une relation très ambivalente avec nos
agriculteurs qu'on accuse d'empoisonner
la planète et en même temps quand ils
vont pas bien on aime passera donc on
est en ce moment quand même les épisodes
de sécheresses à répétition il est moyen
quoi donc le dont il commence à y avoir
l'allemagne c'est pareil la pologne
c'est pareil enfin je veux dire une
énorme partie de l'europe souffre de la
sécheresse maintenant et puis c'est que
le début alors la bonne question c'est
est-ce que ça varié attend c'est plutôt
ça la bonne question moi je pense que ça
va les claques vont finir par se répéter
de telle manière qu à un moment la
population va dire non mais attendez
occupons nous du problème quoi vraiment
on veut plus rester comme ça la question
c'est à ce moment là qu'est ce qui se
passe
et est ce qu il se passe des bonnes
réponses ou est ce qu'il se passe des
mauvaises réponses parce que jusqu'à
maintenant par exemple en france la
réponse en terme de politique
énergétique au problème a été une
mauvaise réponse s'est occupé d'un
prologue qui n'en était pas un et on
s'est pas occupé du vrai problème
la suisse fait un peu pareil soit dit en
passant
donc le enfin vu de ma part après vu de
ma fenêtre
les allemands font totalement pareil
y at il des pays qui ne font pas pareil
oui les revendique les scandinaves les
grands bretons et les pays de l'est
aurait envie de faire des choses qui
sont globalement plus rationnelle la
pologne par exemple elle veut se
débarrasser son charbon dans la foi du
nucléaire et des renouvelables
ce que je trouve tout à fait sensé en
tout cas beaucoup plus intelligent que
ce que font les allemands qui consiste à
se débarrasser d'abord du nucléaire et
avoir ensuite pour le charbon
il ya un papier que je viens de repérer
dans la presse allemande je l'avais pas
vu
il ya deux jours qui a été publié en
juillet dernier de deux anciens anciens
anciens ou récemment anciens anti
nucléaire en allemagne
deux chercheurs et qui disent bon dans
le contexte actuel inverser l'ordre des
priorités faire mais d'abord le lignite
et nucléaire on verra ensuite d'accord
et si vous faites ça plutôt que de
fermer d'abord le nucléaire et ensuite
le lean it on économise 10% nos
émissions de co2 pareil 1 10% des
émissions de co2 alors je trouve que
c'est un signal faible intéressant parce
que ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui
disent bon ben je change mon ordre de
priorité et on va tous devoir le faire
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure de
l'énergie c'est que ces systémique et
donc changé notre rapport à l'énergie
c'est que tous quelque part ou inclus on
va devoir changer un ordre de priorité
de quelque chose et ça va nous coûter
c'est absolument c'est absolument
évident donc ce qui va nous faire passer
à l'action c'est des baffes
parce que on est des animaux câblé pour
réagir à ce que nous disent nos sens et
réagir à ce que nous dit notre cortex
c'est plus compliqué on a plus de mal à
savoir faire ça et ça fait partie de mon
fatalisme dont je parlais tout à l'heure
alors nos sens nous disent quoi soit que
le système devient ingérable sur le plan
des conséquences du changement
climatique ou d'une autre nuisance
environnementale ya un autre truc qui
perturbe de plus en plus de gens en ce
moment c'est la baisse de la
biodiversité y compris dans des
manifestations très quotidienne on
entend les oiseaux chanter on en voit
moins il ya pas les mois quand j'étais
gamin enfin que tous disent tous les
vieux les vieux barbon dans mon genre
c'est quand on était gamins et comporter
en vacances en voiture pour ceux qui
avaient la chance de le faire
il y avait des moustiques qui s'écrasait
sur le pare-brise a et déboucheront et
des mouches tsé-tsé en arriver le pare
brise était constellée d'insectes n'y a
plus un bon moi je me rappelle vraiment
qu'on était obligé de mettre les
essuie-glaces et la nuit il y avait là
on faisait pas 3 mètres en bagnole sans
qu'ils aient les papillons qui viennent
s'écraser sur les phares je me rappelle
qu'à la fin d'un voyage de nuit en
voiture
il fallait
frottez la vitre des phares parce que il
y avait plein d'insectes qui était venu
s'écraser contre 10 aujourd'hui
maintenant même s'ils sont plus profilé
les verts également d'origine l'écocide
cédé un petit écocide parce que la
section c'était aux abords des routes
mais des intérêts par tous les parents
globalement depuis jusqu'à maintenant le
seul endroit où je le seul endroit où je
retrouve aujourd'hui l'impression que
j'avais quand j'étais gamin et que je me
baladais dans le jardin de mes parents
c'est dans les alpages suisses c'est à
dire dans les alpages ya des endroits où
on peut pas faire trois mètres sans
déranger 50 sauterel bon bah quand
j'étais gamin mon jardin de mes parents
qui habitent en région parisienne afin
qu'ils habitaient c'était pareil je veux
dire je faisais je dérangeais les qui
voit des sauterelles dans son jardin en
ville aujourd'hui il y en a plus plus
personne nulle part bon on était enfin
je veux dire c'est que c'était un
insecte commun dans les abords des
villes quand quand j'étais gamin donc il
ya des choses auxquelles les gens
commencent à être sensibles le seul
problème c'est que les conséquences
observable de ces deux causes qui ont
une très forte inertie fait que quand on
commence à agir dessus il ya un tout
petit effet titanic qui fait que c'est
pas complètement sûr qu'on puisse faire
mieux que d'avoir l'iceberg qui vous et
ventre le flanc inertielle et de quoi 30
ans car alors sur le climat c'est vrai
ça dépend sur quoi sur les espèces
disparues elle est infinie c'est une
fois que ces disparus il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière sur le la montée en
température
l'inertie lé de quelques siècles on va
dire c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment
où on a dépassé la températures
préindustrielles le temps qu'on y
revienne il va se passer quelques
siècles où quelques millénaires le temps
qu'on revienne au niveau de la mer pré
industriels il va se passer plus de dix
mille ans va lui arriver ça dépend du
compartiment qu'on garde mais mais
globalement ce qu'il faut retenir comme
comme comme conséquence la conclusion
principale c'est que la totalité des
gens qui nous regardent et de leurs
enfants et de leurs petits enfants et de
leur arrière petits enfants et encore un
certain nombre de générations derrière
ne vivront plus jamais dans un climat
stable
c'est à dire que le climat va connaître
une dérive ça sera ça son état donc on
sera en permanence dans un climat
empreint de dernier pour toi c'est
giannakis et à oui c'est sûr si ça a
commencé ça c'est bon ça recommence et
la raison à cela
on en revient à la physique c'est que le
temps qu'il faut pour évacuer totalement
un surplus de co2 une fois qu'on a mis
dans l'atmosphère et qu'on arrête les
émissions c'est plus de dix mille ans
donc de toutes façons le climat dans
quelques siècles quoi qu'on fasse le
niveau de l'océan aura monté de quelques
mètres
parce que la fonte du groenland est
enclenchée parce que la calotte
antarctique de l'ouest est un risque de
déstabilisation parce que l'eau se
dilate quand on l'a chauffé parce que
tous les glaciers des moyennes latitudes
sont en train de fond de toute façon
quoi qu'on fasse une partie des forêts
sont condamnés une cour fasse voilà
c'est triste mais c'est comme ça enfin
des espèces poussant là où elles
poussent alors si on se dépêche de
couper les êtres et les remplacer par
des pins on peut discuter mais sinon
donc il ya il ya plein de
deux choses pour lesquelles le coup est
parti malheureusement et l'élévation de
température qui est le marqueur
principal de la dérive du climat qu'on
va avoir dans les 20 ans qui viennent
est indifférente à nos émissions c'est à
dire que c'est top en totalité le reflet
des émissions déjà passé qui embarque
l'évolution climatique des 20 années à
venir et on peut plus rien y faire ces
lois de la physique donc le don claque
le problème vis-à-vis du changement
climatique c'est que l'inertie est telle
que le l'image du titanic est la bonne
il ya un moment où on commencera à des
six à se décider à agir une partie de ce
qui doit se produire ne peut de toute
façon plus être évités toujours
exactement on sait que de toute façon on
va se taper une partie de l'iceberg
avec un peu de bol il fondera un peu
plus tôt il sera en plus tu sais
qu'ensuite sans vote régulièrement
oui les votations a exactement et puis
là on va voter soit 7 27 septembre puis
on a cinq sujets oui moi je trouve
qu'ils sont tous reliés d'une certaine
manière évidemment au climat et puis je
voulais aller prendre un non pas pour te
dire ce que tu en penses
est-ce que tu penserais vote et toi mais
plutôt le lien que tu vois avec le
climat d'accord le le pr la première au
premier objet donc au niveau fédéral en
a 5 à au moins un dessin que je crois
connaître qui est sur la chasse non oui
exactement
le premier c'est points négocié une
immigration modéré donc ça c'est
uniquement les dossiers c'est donc
l'extrême droite ce qui pourrait être
chez vous en france nationale a
introduit la votation
oui c'est tout à fait celle qui a déposé
le projet laquelle l'initiative par
l'initiative voilà ils ont récolté des
signatures pour dire ya trop d'étrangers
chez nous d'accord il faut qu'on
récupère la souveraineté sur nos
frontières
donc ça le mot souveraineté et
fonctionne c'est bien en suisse puisque
on a des accords avec l'union européenne
par rapport à ça
et qu'en fait c'est lié à plein d'autres
accords parce que nous on n'est pas dans
l'union européenne on avait refusé ça
dans l'espace schengen
voilà exactement et puis du coup c'est
aussi lié à d'autres à d'autres
relations aussi commercial c'est-à-dire
qu'on a fait ce qu'on appelle des
accords bilatéraux voilé puis donc lui
décès dit il faut que cet accord la
chine ganay sur sur le l'immigration on
l'a on l'enlève dans cambrai le plein
pouvoir mais évidemment si on fait ça
l'europe à dire bah tous les autres
tombent aussi mais disent maintenant on
s'en fout nous on veut notre nain
pouvoir et toi tu dis souvent si on
réagit pas et bien le résultat c'est
qu'il y aura des milliards de gens qui
pourront plus vivre dans leurs lieux et
puis finalement signé rond dans les
lieux où on peut encore vivre et que ce
sera la guerre totale donc l'immigration
elle est aussi hélas déjà d'ailleurs
commencé je pense dû au climat et c'est
une question plus compliqué même si là
dedans évidemment on comprend qu'il ya
des relents xénophobes et puis qu'on
veut pas que nos très jeunes et ils
viennent pas juste parce que l'étranger
il faut lui remettre la faute dessus
mais cette question de l'immigration
elle est à mon avis elle vaut la peine
d'être été je voulais aborder ce sujet
là avec toi alors le les mouvements de
populations ont deux lien avec le sujet
que je traite le premier lien c'est que
ils sont possibles à large échelle et
dans un laps de temps relativement bref
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'énergie
quand les gens n'ont que leurs jambes
pour marcher et qu' il faut qu'ils
trouvent de quoi s'alimenter tout le
long de leur trajet jusqu'au moment où
ils vont dans l'endroit de destination
les mouvements migratoires sont beaucoup
plus lents et globalement moins massif
donc il ya un premier sujet à premier
premier lien avec le prince il ya un
deuxième
il ya un deuxième
lien qui est que la migration en général
elle se fait jamais de gaieté de coeur
pascal inverse la suisse a aussi connu
dans l'autre sens des commerçants par
exemple des gens qui aller loin pour
gagner leur croûte
parce que dans la montagne il n'arrivait
pas à vivre et donc ils étaient obligés
d'aller faire autre chose ailleurs et
tout ou partie du temps et même une
partie étaient obligés d'aller se battre
pour le vatican suisse garde risque est
encore suisse donc tous les peuples ont
réagi de la même manière
historiquement en général y bouge quand
chez eux ça se passe pas bien
oui bouche préférentiellement quand chez
eux ça se passe pas bien au moins en
différentiel avec ailleurs où ça
pourrait se passer mieux oui en général
ça se passe pas bien aussi parce que on
va voler leurs ressources ou qu'on va
peu importe ce qu'ils n'ont pas de quoi
manger
en général quand il ya une insuffisance
alimentaire quelque part le système
politique est jamais extrêmement
libérale jamais extrêmement sympathique
enfin tout ça va ensemble seront
extrêmement voilà la boîte occident ça
c'est la version récente mais
historiquement ça n'a pas toujours été
comme ça d'une manière générale les
troubles politiques et les insuffisances
de ressources ont souvent ensemble le
délégué rossi alors donc ces gens là
donc en gros le début de la pression
migratoire sur les gens que l'effet de
fait que les gens arrivent quelque part
c'est qu'ils sont partis de quelque part
et le changement climatique va augmenter
le nombre de gens qui vont vouloir
partir de quelque part parce que il y
aura un une inadéquation croissante
entre les ressources disponibles
localement et la population présente
localement il ya un troisième point
qu'il faut pas évacuer qui est la
question démographique
il est évident que les pays à croissance
démographique rapide donc la bonne
question à ce moment c'est pas est-ce
qu'ils ont tort ou raison
c est ce que moi en tant que pays
occidental je peux y faire quelque chose
dans le respect des droits fondamentaux
humains et la réponse est quand même oui
je veux citer trois exemples après c'est
les pays qui ont à la fois une
croissance démographique rapide et une
insuffisance de ressources pour gérer
cette croissance démographique s'est
rien passé a bouffé cdpi potentiel des
migrations alors pas nécessairement très
loin à l'essentiel des gens ils émigrent
ont jamais pour venir jusqu'en suisse
ils vont commencer par immigrés chez les
voisins qui peuvent être asiatiques
africains etc
mais quand il s'agit du proche orient
les voisins ça peut être européen quand
il s'agit du maghreb les voisins ça peut
être européen ces gens là ils sont pas
plus diabolique que nous pas moins ils
font comme tous les êtres humains de la
terre c'est vrai il cherche à assurer
leur subsistance et celle de leurs
proches est donc pour eux l'arbitrage
c'est jenny alors ça évidemment ça fait
pas toujours les affaires des gens chez
qui vont des fois oui des fois non donc
la suisse est très contente d'avoir des
frontaliers dans un certain nombre de
secteurs toujours les italiens les
portugais construit la suisse
littéralement voilà comme exactement
comme la france une partie de la france
a été construite dans les espagnols les
portugais les algériens donc il ya un
rapport toujours très ambivalents des
pays à l'immigration il ya les bons et
les mauvais
ça dépend ça dépend de les perdre et des
périodes ça dépend des nationalités ça
dépend de la facilité à s'intégrer
culturellement c'est évidemment beaucoup
plus facile dans un pays comme la suisse
d'intégrer des judéo chrétien que
d'intégrer des gens qui sont pas de
cette culture
enfin voilà ce qu'est ce qui est c'est
pas de diaboliser ni diabolique ni
angéliques de dire ça je veux dire c'est
l'avis des voix là encore quand il ya un
peu de diversité qui arrive ça s'intègre
facilement quand c'est la diversité qui
domine c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est toujours été comme ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'intégrer des gens
quand l'économie est en croissance
rapide donc les américains ils ont
intégré sans aucun problème des
irlandais des italiens des polonais des
français des allemands des et ses
attentes en qui il ya des indiens pour
faire de la place
il y avait la place d'accueillir tous
ces braves gens et ça a fonctionné assez
longtemps comme comme attelage donc
c'est tout ça est vraiment c'est
vraiment une affaire de rapport entre la
taille des gens qui arrivent quelque
part qui eux-mêmes dépendre du
changement climatique et la taille les
ressources disponibles localement pour
les accueillir
qui dépendent aussi du climat et
l'énergie puisque l'énergie conditionne
la prospérité économique et l'accès aux
ressources dont l'équation énergie et
climat elle est au fonds central dans la
façon de prendre le problème de
l'immigration
c'est absolument évident donc ces quatre
ans que tu es en train de dire si je
résume siec si on travaille avec force
sur le climat maintenant on aura moins
problèmes d'immigration afin d'attribuer
cette évidence pour diminuer enfin
diminuer la pression migratoire
elle elle s'obtient de deux manières
elle s'obtient en minimisant la quantité
d'emmerdements que les pays d'émigration
vont devoir gérer et donc ça ça passe
notamment par le fait qu'il n'est pas un
problème d'insuffisance de ressources à
cause du client et ça passe par une
limitation de leur démographie
et là il ya trois choses utiles que
peuvent faire les pays occidentaux c'est
de consacrer la totalité de leur aide au
développement à l'éducation des femmes
ou l'empowerment des femmes pour le plus
précis parce qu'on constate que sa
baisse les taux de nos existences montée
en puissance mais je trouve que le terme
des barbares mais on comprend bien ce
que ça veut dire
parce que de fait c'est expérimental sa
baisse le taux de natalité
la deuxième chose c'est l'accès alors là
c'est dans les limites de ce qui est
culturellement acceptables mais aux
moyens de contraception voir à
l'avortement ça c'est toujours des
choses qui sont culturellement sensibles
mais de fait
ça marche et puis la troisième chose
c'est les systèmes de solidarité parce
que tant qu'il n'existe pas de système
par exemple d'assurance maladie ou de
retraite dans un pays on compte sur sa
famille pour s'occuper de vous si vous
êtes malade ou vieux et à ce moment là
la logique vous pousse à faire plein
d'enfants pour assurer aux vieux joueur
c'est votre retraite quoi exactement
votre capital retraite si mauvaise donc
dans tout ça c'est lent parce que ça
suppose de toucher à des schémas
culturels que les gens doivent le faire
parce qu'ils en soient eux mêmes
convaincus s'ils le font sous la
contrainte c'est plus compliqué voilà
mais c'est donc il ya des moyens
d'action directe et indirecte est ce que
les pays occidentaux qui ne souhaitent
pas à voir arriver trop de monde chez
eux ce qui est un sujet que je ne réfute
pas c'est à dire que j'ai pas où tu
habites mais enfin si tout d'un coup il
ya juste à côté quinze personnes qui dit
tiens on va venir s'installer chez toi
parce que chez nous il ya des fuites
d'eau il fait trop chaud il fait trop
froid etc
tu as 10 rebonds 1 une semaine c'est
vrai bien enfin 15 en permanence pour
être on va discuter bon donc on a tous
une tolérance à devoir partager notre
espace avec une quantité
considérée comme excessive d'autres
personnes si on est tous fait comme ça
ce que moi je trouve désagréable dans ce
genre de débat c'est quand on commence à
mettre un système de valeurs entre soi
et les autres gérants considèrent que
soit on est mieux que les autres et que
les autres ils sont moins bien en fait
on est tous pareils on a tous la même
hiérarchie des préférences sa peau avant
celle des autres et c'est exactement
tous pareil donc il est bon les gens qui
viennent chez nous sont pas plus
malfaisant que les gens qui les
accueillent ils sont fait pareil et ils
ont les mêmes schémas mentaux
et la deuxième chose que ça s'exprime
pas culturellement de la même manière
mais c'est exactement les mêmes schémas
mentaux
et la deuxième chose surtout c'est que
si on veut diminuer la pression le plus
utile et de très loin
c'est pas de s'occuper de la barrière à
l'entrée c'est de s'occuper de la
pression dans l'est dans les pays
démocratiques
voilà ce que c'est bien sûr la partie la
deuxième effectivement le votation qu'on
a c'est la modification sur la loi sur
la chasse
oui moi je suis pas un expert mais tous
les partis écologiques et la gauche
disent plutôt non et la droite plutôt
oui parce que en fait l'idée ce serait
de pouvoir tuer les loups parce que
maintenant les loups sont venus puis
depuis qu'ils ont été introduits en
italie et puis on en suisse c'est déjà
un petit territoire donc semblerait-il
pose problème puisque mange quelques
moutons et quelques chèvres et pourtant
il ya des dédommagements qui sont donnés
aux éleveurs
mais le loup peut-être fait peur
également
du coup l'idée c'est de pouvoir tuer le
loup plus facilement parce que pour
instaurer des règles assez strictes
et puis en contrepartie on cherche
d'autres espèces un petit peu moins
c'est un peu l'idée parce qu'en suisse
on est toujours dans la recherche de
compromis tu sais alors voilà on passe
des trucs et puis voilà le package qui
est sorti par rapport à ça je suis donc
on ne voit pas un expert de la chose moi
je l'ait compris comme ça
personnellement je si les partis
écologistes disent non je ne sais pas
que je suis un mouton mais j'ai lu les
choses ça me paraît assez sens c'est de
dire que non c'est juste un petit sûr
qu'on essaie de nous faire passer pour
nous faire croire qu'on protège
l'environnement alors que c'est pas
réellement le cas est-ce que tu as lu un
peu les choses venant de pension selon
la loi sur la chasse j'ai pas regardé
dans les détails il est hué du loup
c'est ce que cette époque ni rien ni
pour ni contre
je pense que la chasse est un
globalement l'expression
pardon je vais essayer de distinguer
deux choses il ya la motivation
individuelle du chasseur qui peut être
un sujet de débats et après il ya la
pression exercée par la chasse sur
l'environnement qui est d'un deuxième
sujet de débat qu'en france on chasse
les sangliers
j'ai rien contre je veux dire des
sangliers y en a partout
il y en a plein c'est donc
j'ai pas une espèce menacée confiance
des 100 bureaux très bien moi j'ai pas
envie d'aller le faire il ya des tas
d'autres trucs que j'ai pas envie
d'aller faire et d'autres ont envie
d'aller faire donc si l'on ambitieuse et
les sangliers très bien qu'il le fasse
je crois en plus que les statistiques
montrent que l'essentiel des balles
perdues ou tuent d'autres chasseurs donc
c'est un problème balles perdues c'est
un problème interne au chasseur donc
qu'à se démerder pour gérer le truc
entre eux donc voilà inversement qu'on
chasse des gypaètes barbus ou des oies
qui dont les effectifs sincèrement merde
parce que je trouve regrettable que l'on
porte atteinte à la biodiversité sur des
espèces dans les effectifs sont en
souffrance alors que les effectifs de
sangliers ou de chaleur et en france ça
pullule factions est en croissance
voilà donc j'ai un g1 premiers
considérants j'ai envie de dire qui est
l'état des populations chassées
je n'ai pas d'avis sur l'état des
populations chassées en ce qui concerne
le loup parce que selon qu'on envisage
de tuer un loup parents ou la moitié des
loups chaque année j'en aurai pas
nécessairement de ma vie ça leur a donc
cessé lorsque j'essaye de faire
comprendre à travers ce que je suis en
train de réponse et que dans tous ces
débats un peu technique et qui porte sur
des chiffres c'est toujours très
difficile dure et c'est un problème mais
alors là qui est commun avec le mien
c'est toujours très difficile d'arriver
à une position sans prendre le temps de
regarder les choses dans des bras et de
comprendre et c'est ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à la fin du fin les sociétés humaines
n'aime pas les conclusions techniques
elles ne sont pas mises en mouvement par
les sociétés par des conclusions
techniques elles sont mis en mouvement
par des règles de morale et des des
considérations sur le bien et le mal
donc ce qui à l'arrivée et c'est
toujours très difficile pour les
organisateurs de débats d'arriver à
passer par une frange intermédiaire
pendant laquelle on quitte le bien et le
mal
exactement on essaye de leur donner un
contenu un peu normatif un peu
quantifier un peu un peu de prendre un
peu de hauteur de vue pour arriver à la
fin sur des conclusions qui reviennent
au bien et au mal parce que c'est un
truc qu'on est capable de comprendre
mais en étant passé par toute une strate
intermédiaire qui permet dit quand même
de prendre un peu de hauteur de vue
là-dessus sur la loi sur la chasse j'ai
pas d'avis exactement à cause de ça mais
mais pour moi il ya quand même cette
idée que ben surtout les grands
prédateurs
si tu dis qu'il ya tout un coulis
sangliers qui explosent ou qu'il ya une
une espèce qui est un trop plein c'est
parce que l'être humain
oui a amené une disruption on est
d'accord les grands prédateurs par
exemple on est d'accord
du coup il ya plus une régulation de la
nature de sueur voilà qui alors après on
arrive dit oui mais il ya trop de
sangliers oui mais c'est parce que vous
avez bouvier le l'equilibre de base
aussi donc moi je serai à ses partisans
du principe de laissons faire la nature
alors ça c'est un peu différent c'est un
peu différent
c'est un débat totalement différent qui
est est-ce qu'il faut faire des airs
sanctuariser au fond où on fout la paix
aux animaux et on les laisse
dépatouiller entre eux
il est allemand oui là on va retomber
sur un problème d'espacé exactement de
ressources contingentes et de
démographie
parce qu'en fait la raison pour la
première raison pour laquelle on
supprime des espaces naturels sur terre
c'est parce qu on convertit sa en
surface agricole qu'on utilise sur place
ou pour l'exportation pour nourrir des
bonshommes le principal driver de enfin
déterminant déclencheur de la
déforestation dans le monde
c'est l'agriculture de ressources qui
sont vivrières locales ou de ressources
qui sont mondialisés qu'il s'agisse du
de la palme en indonésie du soja au
brésil
voilà ensuite en un tiers de forêt ou
encore passablement de forêt ouais alors
pourquoi d'être un tout petit peu la
forêt suisse puisque je me suis quand
même balader par la production de sape
et chanterelles et myrtille à la
probabilité pour que l'on mette des
champs de blé dans les pompes à 40°
demain matin quand même pas extrêmement
élevé parce que l'effort est oui on met
un peu de raisin mais pas trop loin du
fond d'aller
voilà mais enfin après on n'est même pas
les ans on peut pas picoler plus que 24
heures par jour bocca donc à un moment
on est bien obligé de s'arrêter quand
même donc le donc la forêt suisse elle
occupe essentiellement des régions
montagneuses où l'on mettrait jamais des
cultures et quand les hommes ont été
obligés historiquement ce qu'ils ont
fait par exemple en france dans les
cévennes de mettre des cultures en
terrasse c'est vraiment c'était des
cultures de pauvres c'était des cultures
de gagne petit l'iran est poussée des
châtaigniers c'est vrai que c'était
c'était une vie qui était plus plus dur
que la vie de paysan plein donc le don
donc les forêts suisses elles sont là
parce que la suisse est un pays de
montagnes et en fait quand on regarde où
les forêts sont prêts sont préservés de
manière préférentielle dans les pays qui
des forêts c'est là où il ya du relief
donc là où il ya pas de relief un coupon
mais en culture là où il ya du relief
c'est quand même plus en perdant et donc
ça donc ce qui préserve les forêts et
les montagnes
voilà donc pour pour en revenir à la
chasse à la question sur la les réserves
je pense que c'est une évidemment une
bonne idée de sanctuariser quelques
alors il ya un endroit où c'est beaucoup
plus facile de faire ça que à terre
c'est en mer
on va s'éloigner un tout petit peu de la
question climatique encore que mais je
suis un grand partisan des aires marines
protégées parce que ces mêmes les
pêcheurs quand ils finissent par
comprendre l'intérêt pour eux en
deviennent partisans aussi parce que les
poissons sont quand même des êtres assez
prolifique je veux dire un poisson ça
fait des millions 2 donc si vous leur
laissez des bouts de mer où les emmerder
pas du tout géré ou leur dit je me fous
la paix est encore là faites ce que vous
voulez à ce moment là on a quand même un
effet direct et rap assez rapide sur le
repeuplement des zones concernées
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose de
très efficace c'est quelque chose dont
je suis alors bon sauf que le linéaire
côtier maritime de la suisse reste
limitée des navigateurs mondialement
célèbre ah oui bourgnon pardon picard
dans un autre picard il est pas
d'aviateur mais je dirais cela oui
maintenant ils communiqueront sur tout
mais mais mais par contre sur à terre
voilà l'intérêt de la mer c'est que les
hommes habitent peu sur la mer donc on
n'est pas en concurrence avec des sols
avec avec la surface océanique sur terre
on n'est déjà plus en mai c'est une
bonne idée d'avoir des d'avoir des
réserves c'est c'est absolument évident
la fiscalité le troisième point ces
voiles alors là on nous fait le coup on
veut des deux qu'on puisse déduire les
frais de garde des enfants pour les
familles mais quand on fait le calcul
en fait il faut avoir plus de cent mille
francs de 2,2 salaire annuel par famille
pour pouvoir en bénéficier donc en gros
c'est les des familles à larges revenus
enfin d'accord la classe moyenne haute
qui pourra profiter de déduction fiscale
de le cas échéant mais éloignons nous
deux ça la fiscalité et le climat
évidemment il ya un lien fort sur
comment tu vois quelles sont les clés de
ce assez rapidement alors en fait la
fiscalité un lien fort parce que la
fiscalité à la fiscalité peut avoir deux
objets dans le monde moderne
elle peut avoir pour objet de fournir
des recettes à l'état donc c'est son
moyen d'action on voit la puissance
publique d'une manière générale quand
j'ai des tas j'oublie que je suis en
suisse dont il ya pas un état où il ya
un milliard de canton de communes etc
non mais si je met bout à bout les
cantons les communes les et c'est enfin
tous les échelons qui ont des décisions
à prendre et qui ont des recettes fait
des ressources fiscales propres jeux
alors un milliard non mais quel camp
français par endroits c'est pareil et
elle peut avoir un effet elle peut être
conçue pour orienter les comportements
par exemple les taxes sur le tabac sont
censé orienter les comportements vers
une diminution de la tabagie
rien que cette distinction entre
recettes et orientation des
comportements souvent c'est pas clair
alors évidemment il ya une fiscalité
dans le domaine du climat que beaucoup
de gens ou en tête qui la fameuse taxe
carbone c'est à dire j'oriente les
comportements en renchérissant le coût
des combustibles fossiles donc je rends
les carburants routiers plus cher je
rends le gaz et fioul de chauffage plus
cher
je rends le fioul domestique dans le
fuel lourd plus cher pour la marine
marchande
je rends le kérosène plus cher pour les
avions et ces trucs là c'est un vieux
débat jeu j'ai été longtemps partisan de
cette arme là comme arme importante dans
le dispositif est alors en fait j'ai été
partisan à une époque où on avait encore
plus on avait encore beaucoup de temps
devant nous et en 2005 donc publié en
2006 un bouquin qui s'appelait le plein
s'il vous plaît et qui était un livre
dans lequel on expliquer avec mon co
auteur qui est aussi un des cofondateurs
de 44 que on avait un tout petit sujet
avec l'excès de combustibles fossiles
qu'on utilisait et que pour à cause du
problème climatique est par ailleurs à
cause d'une dépendance à un pétrole qui
s'épuise rien jours donc je sais pas si
on va en parler aujourd'hui mais parce
que je pense que ça peut-être déjà
commencé et le du coup il y avait une
bonne manière d'inciter les gens à la
modération c'est est d'augmenter le prix
de ce qu'ils payent pour bénéficier
d'une unité de combustibles fossiles ce
truc là marche très bien si c'est un
signal lent si ça augmente lentement
dans le temps et alors je vais donner
des habitudes quoi oui c'est ça il faut
il faut il faut que ça il faut que ça il
faut qu'on ait quelques dizaines
d'années devant nous pour que ça marche
bien ouais et je vais prendre un
comparatif
très très évident les pays européens qui
ont tous commencé leurs comptes leurs
vies dans l'ère du pétrole après guerre
comme consommateur de pétrole est pas
comme producteurs c'est-à-dire comme
importateur de pétrole ont tous
significativement taxer leurs carburants
pour éviter que les gens en consomment
trop le résultat des courses c'est que
la voiture moyenne vendue en europe à
cause du fait que historiquement les
prix des carburants toujours été
beaucoup plus élevé que dans d'autres
pays qui ont démarré leur vie comme
producteur de pétrole
ils ont tous les états unis par exemple
les états unis en 1939 la production
américaine de pétrole s'étaient les deux
tiers de la production mondiale
en gros et donc les états unis ayant
démarré comme producteur donc comme nos
importateurs leurs horaires du pétrole
ils ont construit des voitures qui
étaient en moyenne deux fois plus grosse
dépense que le carburant était beaucoup
moins cher il y avait une blague quand
j'étais jeune qui était dire que le prix
de l'essence en france et aux états unis
c'était la même chose sauf aux états
unis cité par gallon 1 gallon c'est 4
litres c'est clair qu'il ya des tanks et
les rumeurs puis donc donc donc ça c'est
un effet direct de la fiscalité sur les
carburants très clair un autre effet
direct de la fiscalité sur les
carburants c'est qu'en france
à un moment on s'est mis à avoir une
fiscalité différenciée entre l'essence
et le diesel le diesel est en moins taxé
est temps donc légèrement moins cher
alors que la suisse celle inverse je
sais pas depuis combien de temps celle
inverse mais en suisse est inversé
d'accord ça a toujours été marqué sa
différence la frontière est donc là le
résultat c'est que la part du diesel
dans les ventes neuves en france qui est
déj pourquoi il ya de 20% ou de 30 % il
ya quelques décennies est passé à 70
pour 70 % ce qui veut dire que l'effet
prix ça marche mais ça marche à partir
du moment où on a trente ou quarante ans
devant soi alors en 2005
je pensais qu'on avait quelques dizaines
d'années devant doux puisque moi je
voyais le début des fins de la fin de la
période pour éviter les gros en mer
devant comme on va dire les premières
décennies du xxème siècle
et donc je me dis si on met une taxe
maintenant ça va ça va commencer à
produire des effets significatifs dans
les 20 30 ans qui viennent et ça va on
est encore dans les clous mais
aujourd'hui on est en 2020 on n'a rien
fait de sérieux et donc aujourd'hui on
n'a plus le temps d'attendre donc j'ai
un peu changé et aujourd'hui je pense
que la taxe est encore utile en
complément d'autres politiques mais que
l'essentiel de la politique qui doit
nous permettre d'éviter ce qui peut
encore s'éviter du mur énergétique au
climatique
c'est essentiellement des dispositions
réglementaires interdiction autorisation
normalisation obligation de faire alors
exemple je dis en suisse il ya un label
qui sauf erreur de ma part s'appelle
minergie qui je crois s'applique aux
bâtiments neufs oui eh bien je dis j'ai
tant le label aux bâtiments existants et
je préviens les propriétaires que si
dans 25 ans ils sont pas conformes à ce
label
quand je dis pas que le label minergie
et celui qui va bien c'est juste pour
donner un air d'une contrainte tous ceux
qui ne sont pas à ce niveau là leur
impôt foncier seront multipliées par dix
d'accord ça c'est un signal
réglementaire assorti d'une pénalité ou
bien leurs biens ne sera plus vendable
c'est d'accord je n'ai même pas besoin
de x 10 je dis juste leur truc
épouvantable
ça c'est une arme réglementaire il n'y a
pas de signal prix dans cette histoire
il ya une obligation de faire d'accord
alors ça va se traduire de fait par un
signal prix c'est que les propriétaires
vont devoir dépenser de l'argent et donc
tout ce qu'ils dépenseront là dedans ils
ne donneront pas ni à swissair ni à
rolex ni à coop c'est très clair mais il
ya une obligation de faire deuxième
exemple vous n'êtes pas dans l'union
européenne
mais vous pourriez très bien dire je
fais comme l'union européenne en plus
sérieux puisque l'union européenne s'est
pas assez sérieux je réglemente l'aller
la consommation des voitures neuves
vendues en suisse et je colle une taxe
qui va très fortement croissante en
fonction de la consommation des
véhicules neufs vendus en suisse
alors pour me balader un peu en suisse
alors peut-être que les environs de
lausanne genève et de la vallée du rhône
sont pas représentatifs
enfin il ya quand même une concentration
grosses bagnoles tout à fait tout à fait
respectable et là pour le coup pas très
cohérente pour moi avec l'esprit écolo
suisses telles que même alors un esprit
écolo suisse c'est ce qu'on dit oui
alors je pense après qu' il ya une
histoire écolo suisse sait pas si
l'esprit écolo suisse est encore là je
pense qu'il ya une histoire et colossus
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
l'écologie où exactement le souci de
l'environnement dans les temps anciens
étaient le reflet des contraintes
environnementales réel que les gens
avaient à gérer parce que c'est un petit
pays et donc dans un petit pays n'ayant
pas de façade maritime la limite avec un
hiver qu'il fallait se palucher parce
que passer l'hiver à la montagne c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas drôle et
bien les suisses ont eu une
historiquement une conscience de la
finitude du monde qui était imposé par
leur environnement immédiat
donc il savait ce que c'était et il ya
des il ya des tas de ciste est en fait
la suisse qui est à une collection de
micro communisme c'est à dire le le le
les communes c'est comme un c on mettait
plein de choses en commun
moi il ya une histoire que j'adore c'est
l'histoire d bis dans le valais l'ebit
des chemins pédestres contre alors
maintenant c'est les chemins pédestres
mais historiquement c'est les aqueducs
oui c'est l'adduction d'eau des torrents
de fond de ballet vers les pâturages où
il pleut pas assez et c'est est régi par
tout un système de droits d'eau qui
était gérée de façon collective et c'est
donc c'était très communautariste
de ce point de vue et quand on regarde
les pays qui ont la conscience
environnementale la plus importante
aujourd'hui
globalement j'ai envie de dire c'est
tous des pays qui ont été fortement
contraint géographiquement dans les
temps anciens
donc c'est toi les pays insulaires soit
les pays où l'hiver était très rude
les pays scandinaves
b de montagne et c'est avec les
communications coupées
c'est donc en fait tous ces pays ont une
claire conscience de la finitude du
monde parce que c'était la réalité
j'ai envie de dire physique et
géographique de tous les jours dans les
temps anciens aller à l inverse les pays
qui se sont développés dans un monde aux
ressources face ils ont une conscience
environnementale qui est beaucoup plus
faible alors du coup j'ai perdu le fil
de ma pensée j'étais sur la fiscalité
après la réglementation tu donnais des
exemples dans la rotation
on était dans la votation sur le
des exemples de contraintes oui pardon
alors donc dans les exemples de
contraintes de la réglementation des
véhicules neufs
on pourrait très bien dire en suisse il
est interdit de vendre une voiture qui
consomme plus de 4 litres aux cent
voilà où 4 litres et demi au sens ça
c'est pareil c'est une contrainte
réglementaire alors les distributeurs de
voitures vendues les mains très bien et
que l'on s'en fout en fait vous dire ils
s'adapteront là pour le coup on s'adapte
pis à l'a passé facilement s'il ya que
ça à manger les gens mangent pas voilà
ça serait une décroissance choisie
oui est-ce que non c'est juste pour dire
que l' arme réglementaire est une arme
qui est aujourd'hui à privilégier parce
que son impact est beaucoup plus rapide
que l'armé fiscale et par ailleurs elle
est beaucoup plus lisible sur la façon
dont les acteurs doit s'organiser
si je dis je monte le prix du gaz c'est
pas lisible parce que moi ça me dit pas
à quel horizon de temps je suis sûr de
devoir changer ma chaudière à fuel ou
une chaudière à gaz par une pompe à
chaleur ou par une chaudière à bois
alors que si je dis à une barrière
franche c'est elle date et puis sinon ça
va vous coûter temps c'est beaucoup plus
lisse donc au fil du temps je suis
progressivement passer d'un grand
partisan de la taxe carbone vers un
grand partisan de la taxe carbone slash
la réglementation parce que pour
reprendre l'exemple de ma voiture qui
consomme 4 litres aux cent si on veut
que les gens se déplacent pas plus
qu'avant avec une voiture qui consomme
moins
il faut aussi monter le prix de
l'essence mais au moins on leur a monté
dans un contexte dans lequel le
déplacement reste budgétairement
accessible
c'est donc il faut faire les deux super
intéressant mais on peut plus se
contenter d'un seul instrument
maintenant c'est pas assez directif sur
la façon dont les gens doivent
s'organiser
alors je vois un autre problème qui pour
la suisse du pur pour le coup puisque
c'est vrai que nous on est une
démocratie semi directe en tout cas on
nous consulte avant de prendre des
décisions donc l'autoritarisme où les
décisions fortes contraignantes
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'aime pas du
tout sauf si elles sont consensuelles
exactement mais pour arriver à un
consensus ça prend du temps alors le
grand problème de démocratie sont des
systèmes l'an exactement et la preuve
avec l'élément de votation suivant ça
fait des années et des années qu'on
voudrait donner un petit peu de congé
paternité parce qu'ils figurent toc en
suisse c'est dans la loi c'est un jour
ou deux jours je crois de gens en france
aient pas beaucoup plus long et là on
s'est battu des années des années puis
on va voter pour deux semaines deux
semaines paternité et c'est absolument
pas à qui je pense que ça va passer
parce que les partis centristes se sont
plutôt prononcé en faveur mais tu vois
la haute lutte
donc après pour contraindre c'est
quasiment impossible at on court dans le
temps qu'il faut donc on revient aux
claques donc pas les claques à mon avis
se passera rien je suis d'accord on va
passer directement au dernier point
c'est la gratuité jaguar et commentaires
à faire sur congé paternité quasi les
congés et d'une manière générale
alors là pour le coup il ya un lien
extrêmement direct avec mon sujet c'est
une conséquence de l'énergie
la raison pour laquelle alors il ya
quelques siècles il n'y avait pas
d'énergie abondante il n'existait pas de
congés payés
il existait par le week end
intégralement chaud mais il n'existait
pas non plus de jours fériés hors jours
religieux
voilà il n'existait pas de congé
paternité il n'existait pas plus de
congés maternité il n'existait pas de
retraite la retraite en france j'ai pas
de quand elle date en suisse mais la
retraite en france elle a été instaurée
au début par colbert pour les pour les
marins donc je crois pas beaucoup de
monde donc c'est dans les années 1600
c'est pourquoi bon bref
mais à l'époque c'était des tout petits
régimes et les régimes de retraite
historique c'est les marins les
militaires etc
à 27 ans et tout ça c'est le fruit de
l'abondance enfin tout ce qui est arrivé
derrière c'est le fruit de l'abondance
énergétique parce que l'abondance
énergétique sarah consistait en fait à
faire travailler les machines à le place
donc parce que l'énergie on l'a en fait
il ya un grand malentendu quand on dit
consommer de l'énergie on consomme pas
de l'énergie je veux dire les gens qui
nous écoutent ne boivent pas de pétrole
et mettre les doigts dans la prise en
face ils font ça ils vont pas nous
écouter longtemps non mais surtout
l'énergie en fait je ne consomme pas
nous mêmes on peut dire que on consomme
des tomates ou qu'ils n'en consomment du
pain j'entends bien voire même
concernent des vêtements mais on
consomme pas d'énergie
donc en fait consommer de l'énergie ça
veut dire domestique et enfin ça veut
dire mettre des machines à nos services
en pratique c'est ça ça veut dire yeux
et d'image que j'utilise souvent à mains
non en fait c'est l'approvisionnement
énergétique c'est la nourriture d'iron
man en pièces détachées
c'est à dire que le monde c'est devenu
ironman en pièces détachées
c'est vrai où travaillent pour nous des
laminoirs d'être un des camions des
cimenteries des usines des voitures des
ascenseurs des aspirateurs et des
tourniquets tafer la vinaigrette comme
disait bien oui mais ça va être mis en
corrélation avec notre consommation non
s'ils ont bien sûr beaucoup moins bien
beaucoup moins de machines aussi on est
bien d'accord c'est pareil je veux
revenir pour le moment donc ce que je
dis c'est que les machines possèdent
deux places du coup nous auraient du
temps libre et donc ce temps libre on
peut l'affecter à avoir des études
longues des retraites une limitation de
la durée hebdomadaire de travail le
week-end et c est le congé paternité
donc c'était ça le où je voulais en
venir c'est que en fait
le la création donc je dis pas qu'il
faut pas voter congé paternité est ce
parce que je suis en train de dire ce
que je suis en train de dire c'est que
là l'existence de congé au sens large et
de temps pour soi au sens large c'est
une conséquence de l'abondance
énergétique et il ya souvent des gens
qui lisent dans un monde dans lequel on
sera en décroissance en fait on passera
notre temps à discuter entre nous comme
ça et à jouer aux cartes en buvant des
bières et moi je dis non non pas du tout
c'est un monde dans lequel on va
recommencer à transpirer
il faut pas se leurrer c'est exactement
ça qui va se passer et donc il y aura
moins de temps libre entre guillemets
cela étant le congé le congé paternité
c'est pas censé normalement permettre au
père de se tourner les pouces
au contraire c'est lui permettre de se
lever la nuit pour changer les couches
les groupies y ait un tout petit peu le
lendemain mais
tu en sais quelque chose bon il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont passés par là
mais le donc ce n'est pas nécessairement
une mauvaise idée ce que je dis je sais
que c'est toi tu fais la corrélation que
le temps libre d'une manière générale
est un est vraiment un acquis un acquis
de l'abondance énergétique et dernier
objet l'acquisition de nouveaux avions
de combat figure tard il ya une votation
là dessus oui et en vous demande de
choisir le modèle le non non non non le
budget pour ce pays des avions ça
pendant lesquels la dernière fois
c'était un peu plus précis c'était poule
gripen oui il ya ici des avants parce
que je me suis dit que les finalistes
c'était le rafale est très peu y rester
le groupe aime bien on a pu discuter sur
gripen directement le budget pour
acheter le gripen en savez quoi
maintenant on sait moins quoi parce que
ça du coup ça fait déborder les débats
mais c'est un budget je sais plus
combien il est pour acquérir alors il
faut savoir comme suisse pour traverser
l'espace aérien de la partie la plus
longue donc on l'on se prend six minutes
en avion de chasse
donc on peut effectivement se demander
si on met des milliards et des milliards
pour intercepter un objet aérien qui
auraient passé les forces de l'otan
avant d'arriver chez nous serait
pertinent mais évidemment il ya un lien
directement avec le climat et l'armée
l'armée consomme énormément pour faire
face à quelle menace
est-ce que c'est pertinent tout ça mais
il ya ce lien sécurité parce que ceux
qui vont voter pour il dit non il faut
que la suisse sur sécurisé et puis que
c'est les avions qui sont censés servir
uniquement à la dépense de l'espace
aérien suisse uss est aussi destiné à
éventuellement contribuer à une force de
projection non pour aller se battre
jusqu'au bout au mali dont la neutralité
apparemment on est neutres ensuite la
signification de la neutralité est à
discuter on pourrait en venir
on discute de ça non absolument pas de
force
d'accord c'est vraiment la défense
intérieur uniquement la défense
intérieur d'accord ok alors je n'ai
évidemment strictement aucun avis pour
savoir s'il faut
intense et les milliards dépensés des
milliards ou pas la seule pendant 6
milliards je crois achats plus
exploitation des avions le seul
commentaire que je peux faire c'est que
en france le fonctionnement de l'armée
c'est à peu près 3 % de l'empreinte
carbone d'un français 3 ou 4% alors là
je parle bien de l'empreinte carbone
c'est à dire la totalité des émissions
qui ont lieu n'importe où dans le monde
soit en france ou ailleurs pour fournir
les produits et services que la france
va utiliser
alors quand je dis la france et les
consommateurs finaux mais la
consommation finale peut aussi être le
fait d'une administration ou en voie
d'en perdre on va trouver le pétrole de
l'armée notamment aux états unis l'armée
américaine consomme le tiers du pétrole
consommé en france de mémoire c'est un
pc un petit pays en lui même enfin je
veux dire consommation énergétique s'est
alors les etats unis c'est 20 % du
pétrole mondial en consommation
consommation en production ils sont
plutôt haquin ils doivent être à 16,17
ils sont vachement remontée avec avec le
chinois le alors est-ce que l'armée
suisse doit se doter d'avions je ne sais
pas ouais bah quoi doit on pas forcément
mais par contre la précision enfin je
veux dire je n'ai pas d'avis sur la
question
bon je pourrais avoir un avis non mais
c'est cette idée que ce qu'on n'est pas
une période de l'humanité ou alors
j'étais un peu avec les conneries de se
taper dessus et puis alors ça c'est dans
la sécurité climatique
oui alors j'ai envie de dire il ya
l'éternel débat dans dans le dans les
questions de sécurité entre le glaive le
bouclier et la voyait et la poignée de
main tendue mais oui
c'est un éternel débat et je pense qu'il
ya aussi en ses strahl que les hommes
moi j'ai envie de dire avant de trancher
le débat entre le glaive le bouclier la
poignée de main tendue il ya de toute
façon plein d'autres dépenses sur
lesquelles là je suis capable d'avoir
des avis beaucoup plus tranché on
parlait tout à l'heure de la 5g pour moi
l'assemblée on plie c'est à dire on met
une croix dessus on oublie on passe à
autre chose
donc là on peut déjà économiser quelques
milliards aux quelques dizaines de
milliards en tout cas à l'échelle d'un
pays comme la france et des dizaines de
milliards et en faire autre chose
d'accord moi je ne vois pas l'intérêt
dans mon pays de passer à un truc qui
permet de télécharger un film en trois
secondes plus tôt quand d'une minute
quand toutes les forêts sont en train de
cramer je ne vois pas l'intérêt de
changer tous les smartphones qu'on a en
france au risque d'augmenter l'empreinte
carbone des français de x %
parce que on fait de l'obsolescence
programmée
je ne vois pas l'intérêt d'augmenter le
déficit de la balance commerciale parce
que rien de ce qui sera nécessaire au
réseau 5g ne sera fabriquée chez nous il
est smartphone ni les éléments ni les
routeurs n'y aura rien du tout et je ne
vois pas enfin je vois aucun intérêt jeu
rien de rien et je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de [ __ ] dans l'environnement des
fréquences qui perturbe les observations
météo donc je dire aux intérêts pour moi
là bas pareil pour moi avec un avion qui
violerait l'espace aérien suisse alors
qu'on a dit on à des défenses solaire
donc là je suis capable d'avoir un avis
oui je suis d'accord peut-être que c'est
beaucoup plus pertinent même en restant
dans l'arbitrage des boucliers de
parloir d'avions de chasse et de mettre
le quart du prix dans quelques missiles
voilà en disant si tu me dis si tu
manques le bout de son nez
je te fait des misères c'est
probablement je suis d'accord que mais
c'est un débat strictement là pour le
coup strictement militaire où j'ai pas
de gêne à lens j'ai d'ailleurs j'ai
parlé je comprends bien les termes du
débat mais jugez pas d'avis ouais top
situation de la suisse la situation
énergétique donc tu sais que notre
production énergétique en tout cas
d'électricité elle est en grande partie
de l'attention on va parler d'énergie ou
d'électricité
parce qu'en france mais l'enjeu est donc
le premier terme et la consommation
suisse c'est de pétrole oui exactement 1
49% que je crois de 40 pour moi avec les
transports ok c'était en 2006 de 40% et
après c'est seulement derrière qu'on va
trouver en fait la production
d'électricité en suisse
oui qui représente combien attendent
enfin combien de % de l'énergie du coup
alors l'énergie ça dépend si on
s'intéresse l'énergie à deux termes du
jargon énergétique qu'on appelle
primaire et finale mais tout le monde
est largué l'énergie à 2 alors d'avoir
un premier truc il faut savoir en ce qui
concerne l'énergie c'est que l'énergie
nous ne savons rien faire d'autre que de
la prise après la prélever dans
l'environnement et l'exploiter à notre
profit on ne s'est pas créé d'énergie au
sein de l'humanité à partir de rien non
ça serait formidable ou pas non ça
serait violer le premier principe de la
thermodynamique donc c'est vachement
bien on serait harry potter ou mais en
étant d'avoir des machines comme ça
absolument alors il ya des inventeurs
d'humanité il ya des inventeurs du
mouvement de nouveaux visuels
voilà qui me contactent sur l'énergie
libre pourquoi moi j'en ai un qui me dit
mais vous avez pas que nous étions pas
c'est pas possible
non non ça viole
violent la loi de conservation de
l'énergie donc c'est pas possible donc
hors la loi de conservation de l'énergie
pour ceux qui sont pas familiers dit un
truc très simple c'est que dans un
système qui ne communiquent pas avec
l'extérieur l'énergie se conserve
d'accord donc dans une boîte de conserve
donc le cornet de vivre ce concert est
bien dans un système qui ne communiquent
pas avec l'extérieur l'énergie
concernées elles se conservent
rigoureusement c'est à dire il n'y a pas
un peu plus un pote les séries alors la
conséquence de cette loi de conservation
c'est que les hommes ne peuvent pas
créer de l'énergie en leur sein ils
peuvent juste prendre l'énergie dans
l'environnement exploiter à leur profit
et l'énergie qu'on va prendre dans
l'environnement à exploiter à notre
profit en fait on l'a fait pour ça
passait dans un convertisseur est en
fait toutes les machines sont des
convertisseurs d'énergie à commencer par
nous donc nous on prend de l'énergie
dans l'environnement c'est le
rayonnement solaire
c'est le chocolat en suisse et le
chocolat absolument et la fondue qui
comme dit marina rejoint le pousser le
cac en suisse tu sais voilà s'allumant
qui n'est pas libre aphrodisiaques
ninard holman a fondu mais donc le
comprendre l'environnement
l'énergie sous forme d'alimentation et
sous forme d'apports solaires de la
chaleur d'accord ce qu'ils nous
demandent pas trop manger pour rester à
37° parce que si on était dans un
environnement à -10 en permanence tenue
on n'y arriverait pas donc on a besoin
des deux et on transforme ça en chaleur
qui nous maintient à 37 beaucoup et en
mouvement un peu puis avec le temps on a
réussi puisque l'histoire des hommes et
une transition énergétique perpétuelle
séné que ça on a réussi à domestiquer
d'autres convertisseur utilisant
d'autres sources d'énergie alors on a
domestiqué d'autres êtres biologique les
animaux les esclaves on à domestiquer
les énergies renouvelables le feu le
vent le soleil la force de l'eau
l'europe était couverte de moulins il ya
deux mille ans et puis après avec le
temps on a domestiqué encore d'autres
formes de convaincre d'autres
convertisseur que sur les machines en
métal machine à vapeur moteur à
combustion interne puis on a domestiqué
les moteurs électriques alors pour
donner à manger à toutes ces machines on
a besoin de leur donner les croquettes
spécial là c'est l'énergie en fait donc
le l'énergie c'est des croquettes pour
machines les machines mange de l'énergie
cette énergie qu'on prélève dans
l'environnement s'appelle de l'énergie
primaire primaire première c'est là
qu'on la trouve sauf que les machines ne
mange pas exactement l'énergie qu'on
trouve dans l'environnement par exemple
la voiture c'est très mal des gens qui
vont nous écouter mange des carburants
raffinés elle mange pas du pétrole brut
l'énergie qui va rentrer dans les
machines qu'on utilise ou l'électricité
qui rentre dans une machine à café très
important pour s'habiller le matin
et bien cette énergie là c'est ce qu'on
appelle de l'énergie finale alors finale
parce qu'elle sort elle est enfin du
système énergétique donc en fait
primaires c'est celle qui rentrent dans
le système énergétique comprend dans
l'environnement et final c'est elle qui
sort du système énergétique et qui va
alimenter dans machine par exemple cette
très belle radio qui fonctionne pas il a
fonctionné à une époque où j'imagine
à ce moment-là il mangeait un peu
d'électricité pour fonctionner a besoin
si je prends l'énergie finale ce terreau
celle qui rentre dans les machines et
qui sort du système énergétique
l'électricité dans les pays occidentaux
représente de l'ordre de 20 % de cet
ensemble un peu plus un peu moins ça
dépend des pays donc en suisse comme
dans les autres pays
l'énergie manger par toutes les machines
qu'on va trouver en suisse alors dans
toutes les machines qu'on va trouver
ensuite j'ai à la fois les usines
chimiques de balle les quelques
cimenterie de holcim mais aussi toutes
les voitures que je trouve et le grille
pain qui chez toi c'est toutes les
machines les ascenseurs machin et
l'aspirateur
toutes ces machines là l'électricité
c'est 20% entre 18 et 22 et 23 tout le
reste c'est autre chose et notamment
énormément des carburants raffinés
en france les carburants raffinés
c'est plus de la moitié de l'énergie
finale plus la moitié par contre si je
regarde l'énergie primaire c'est à
l'énergie comprend d'environnement en
garde pour lesquels on comprend bien ce
que ça vaut si je prends du charbon et
le brûle c'est la chaleur du charbon il
ya d'autres énergies pour lesquels c'est
plus compliqué par exemple
hydroélectricité ckoi l'énergie primaire
en fait c'est l'énergie libérée par la
chute d'eau et pour le nucléaire c'est
la chaleur dégagée dans la centrale
c'est ça le qui sert de référence est
alors des fois il ya des énergies pour
lesquels on va convertir sa en
équivalent chaleur libérée dans la
centrale même si ya pas de centrale et
c'est le cas dans les statistiques
internationales précisément pour
l'hydroélectricité et pour l'éolien le
solaire et si je prends l'énergie
primaire à ce moment en suisse
avec les conventions internationales
qu'on a je pense que l'électricité doit
s'approcher des 45% un truc comme ça
dans lesquels l'hydroélectricité faisant
une grosse moitié
je sors une grosse moitié donc on va se
retrouver avec 25% d'hydroélectricité
dans l'énergie primaire mais le pétrole
est à 40 en suisse
voilà donc la première énergie primaire
comme finale consommée en suisse c'est
des produits pétroliers dans les grosses
voitures qui circulent sur l'autoroute
s'ils sont plus émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre aux audi et mercedes
il y avait de plus en plus d'actions la
sortie qu'ovide achetez vous allez
suivez vous serez heureux et donc vous
avez vous avez même pas l'excusé d'avoir
une industrie automobile qui a envie non
alors que douchez l'excusent qu'on a
enfin je veux dire par essence dont on a
raison de le faire des fois oui non pas
au sens de ces on a raison de le faire
et c'est en ce sens qu'il ya des
construite il ya des constructeurs qui
dit ça on va creuser si et c'est alors
que vous avez même pas cette excuse et
tu es ce que tu trouves que c'est une
bonne excuse par exemple là on a
renfloué l'aviation par exemple alors
que clairement il faudrait diminuer
moi je pense qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire
mais du coup ça la contrepartie c'est il
ya plein de gens qui vont être au
chômage
bah oui alors c'est alors ils vont être
au chômage de toute façon un jour parce
que les craquements dans ce système que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
font que de toute façon des gens vont se
retrouver au chômage plus tard
en fait il ya longtemps que comme
d'autres pays occidentaux la suisse
n'aurait pas dû encourager le
développement du transport aérien alors
l'encourager elle a fait comme tous les
pays occidentaux et la france encore
plus que d'autres puisque on a une
industrie qui en vit une de nos
premières industries à l'exportation en
france et airbus
donc on en plus que d'autres et là je
vais en profiter pour dans le monde
économique rappeler quelque chose quand
des lobbys économiques qui ne sont
qu'une partie des lobbys il faut le
rappeler
il ya aussi des lobbys
environnementalistes il y à des lobbys
sociaux les syndicats
bien sûr oui c'est vrai mais avec des
moyens je suis pas en train de parler
des moyens je suis en train de parler de
l'intention ok l'oni le lobby est un
corps constitués qui a le souhait d'
infléchir la politique publique c'est ça
sa définition et point barre
alors qu'après certains gagnent la
bataille et d'autre la perte c'est un
problème mais je lâche enfin définir les
pièces sur les clés et les pièces sur
l'échiquier c'est qu'un lobby et dechy
project essaye d'être un lobby aussi je
l'assumé totalement
or c'est des gens qui ont envie que soit
la raison d'influer sur la décision
publique c'est saint louis alors dans le
l'économie quand on parle de quand les
lobbys économiques dit ça va faire du
mal à l'économie
en fait on ne sait jamais de quelle
économie il parle est ce que ça va faire
du mal aux actionnaires est ce que ça va
faire du mal aux salariés
est ce que ça va faire du mal acquis à
qui ça va faire du mal
et alors moi dans cette histoire j'ai
actionnaires j'imagine exactement les
gens qui gueulent en général ils sont
plus préoccupés de la valeur des actions
que du nombre de gens qu'ils emploient
complètement alors même que il invoque
l'exact inverse
oui quand ils lisent soutenait mon
secteur le
parce que souvent les représentants sont
des dirigeants que les dirigeants sont
plus intéressés à la valeur de l'action
qui au nombre de gens qui travaillent
chez eux dit autrement si leurs bonus
était indexée sur le nombre de gens qui
ne fichent pas à la porte et pas du tout
sur la valeur des actions
peut-être qu'ils auraient des
comportements un peu différent le donc
donc genre pour en revenir à ce que
disait l'économie de mon point de vue et
je suis actionnaire
moi je suis copropriétaire de
l'entreprise dans laquelle je travaille
je considère que l'actionnaire il a pris
un risque en étant actionnaire de son
entreprise et que dans sa prise de
risque il ya la possibilité qu'il perde
son investissement donc moi aujourd'hui
les seules actions d'entreprises que je
défends que je détiens pardon sont dans
l'entreprise dans laquelle je travaille
car 24 j'en ai pas d'autre et je
considère que le risque que je prends
c'est que ça peut très bien demain matin
valoir 0 et je veux dire ai pleuré nulle
part en dira c'est pas juste
non c'est la règle du jeu d'action dans
l'entreprise
ce qui est important quand on se
préoccupe de l'avenir des secteurs
économiques
c'est pas les actionnaires ses salariés
donc ce qui est important quand on
décide qu'à un secteur économique à
moins de raison d'être que de par le
passé il ya eu plein d'occasions où ça a
été décidé j'en reviens aux etats unis
ils ont fait plein d'avions de chasse
pour la seconde guerre mondiale une fac
la seconde guerre mondiale c'est calme
et il n'y avait pas de raison d'en faire
autant donc les gens qui fabriquait les
avions de chasse et il a fallu qu'il
fallait qu'il se remette à faire autre
chose
bon bah on le fait et voilà c'est comme
ça donc la vraie le vrai sujet c'est
comment est-ce qu'on s'occupe des gens
qui travaillent dans le secteur et qu'on
s'occupe de leur trouver un job ailleurs
de quelle manière il ya plein de
manières de gérer le problème
on peut gérer ça au fil des départs en
retraite et des entrées on peut leur
faire il ya plein de il ya plein de
manières mais il faut il penser
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à partir du
moment où des secteurs qui ne peuvent
pas croître indéfiniment ni même rester
indéfiniment en l'état refuse de 2,2 de
discuter de la possibilité que leur
secteur globalement se contracte alors
que à un moment ou un autre à inexorable
eh bien on augmente la probabilité que
ça se passe mal c'est à dire la barque à
travers des accidents et
des baffes il est parfaitement possible
que le secteur aérien ne reviennent
jamais au niveau auquel il était en 2019
c'est parfaitement possible malgré tout
les milliards qu'ils sont mis dedans je
dis pas que ça va être le cas mais c'est
parfaitement possible que ce soit le cas
pour je vois au moins deux raisons à ça
la première c'est que il est
parfaitement possible que la planète ait
passé son pic d'extraction du pétrole en
2010 9 exactement en novembre 2018 ça a
été le cas sur le pétrole conventionnel
en 2008 et le pétrole non conventionnel
c'est à dire le pétrole de roche-mère le
shale oil aux états unis et les sables
bitumineux du canada ont rassuré le
relais de croissance entre 2008 et 2018
ça avait commencé à baisser depuis 2018
ça c'est pas le vide qui est avec ce qui
se passe sur le corps vidé le fait que
les investissements dans l'amont
pétrolier se sont cassé la gueule et qu'
il ya une partie des comporte etc il ya
le patron de bp qui a annoncé il ya
trois jours que il pensait que jamais le
pétrole allaient n'allaient plus
augmenter la consommation de pétrole
n'allait pas augmenter donc à ce moment
là ça va globalement freiner les
échanges et la mondialisation dont le
transport aérien est un des des
composantes
donc il est parfaitement possible que le
transport aérien et mangé son pain blanc
et qu'ils ne reviennent jamais au niveau
et ainsi en plus on y rajoute à ça la
trouille
alors que moi je trouve injustifiées
mais en l'occurrence elle m'arrange bien
que les gens ont de mourir s'ils sont
les uns à côté des autres dans un
transport en commun qui s'applique aussi
à l'aérien et bien à ce moment
est ce qu'il ya en plus vrai pour une
partie des retraités septuagénaires ou
octogénaires qui court le monde
à ce moment il est parfaitement possible
que le transport aérien ne reviennent
pas à son niveau même si on injecte des
milliards de da ok ok le lobbying
c'est la voie que tu as choisie pour
infléchir il ya d'autres moyens
il ya les jeunes notamment qui sortent
dans les rues qui font la grève
extinction est un lobby c'est un lobby
aussi puisqu'il demande quelque chose
c'est un lobbyiste en rédige pour
demander quelque chose ils dans leur
extinction rébellion oui oui oui tout ça
c'est des lobbys mais c'est pas
péjoratif dans ma bouche loïc c'est un
groupe d'intérêts qui cherchent à faire
pression et c'est parce que comme on a
l'habitude de perdre face au lobby ben
du coup cela on a l'habitude
tu as l'habitude les choses qui te sont
chers voilà perdent la survie de
l'humanité que ton lobby perd 2 face aux
lobbys économiques voilà tu as
l'habitude de ça c'est ça mais ça veut
pas dire de cette sémantique
qu'est-ce qui pense ceci étant dit de
ces des pratiques de ses mouvements et
cette jeunesse alors je pense qu'il faut
l'entendre
j'ai coutume de dire c'est marrant parce
qu'il n'ya pas très longtemps j'ai été
interviewé par arte sur le nucléaire
parce qu'apparemment friday sport de
futures a pris position sur le sujet
mais moi je trouve que la croisade de
greta tony berg au début était une
croisade extrêmement salutaire parce
qu'au fond le message principal qu'elle
aimait et le message principal qui
viennent des mouvements jones est on est
angoissé écoutez le on a l'impression
que votre notre avenir ne vous apporte
pas c'est pas qu'il ait compromis on a
l'impression que vous ne faites rien
c'est très différent
cité sur un bateau qui coule et que tu
es un enfant et que tu vois ton père
toi tu as l'impression que dans l'avenir
est compromis c'est absolument certain
mais que tu vois ton père mettre à l'eau
le canot de sauvetage te donner son
gilet de sauvetage dire vas-y survie etc
et moi je verrais derrière ton avenir
est compromis mais tu n'a au moins pas
le sentiment que
tes parents sont indifférents à la chose
là je pense que ce qui est une c'est
l'expression d'une injustice qui est on
a l'impression qu'une partie du monde
est en train de s'écrouler autour de
nous et vous ça vous fait ni chaud ni
froid vous en foutez vous continuez à
vous occuper du cours de bourse
c'est à peu près ça le bon est envoyé
dans quoi ils ont raison moyennant quoi
ils ont raison donc le là là donc je
pense que c'est des mouvements qui sont
salutaires dans l'expression d'une
angoisse ce que dit greta tony berg au
fond c'est jeu l'angoissent m'étouffe
fait quelque chose et ce qu'elle rajoute
c'est la première chose que vous
pourriez faire et c'est exactement ce
que j'ai dit au début de cet entretien
c'est au moins prenez le temps de
comprendre le problème quoi documentez
vous je veux dire il ya de la
littérature scientifique et là sur la
table qui qui qui qui a pris le banc il
se trouve que j'ai je sais pas si ça lui
est parvenue mais j'ai envoyé un message
j'ai jamais eu de réponse mais j'ai
envoyé un message à son équipe sur son
site internet en disant que moi si
j'étais à sa place je refuserai de
rencontrer les
et responsables politiques genre obama
et autres qui n'ont pas déjà lu la
littérature scientifique mais après ça
en condition préalable c'est pas je vous
vois à 10 heures de cours boom
je vous vois et vie et puis vous allez
me dire que vous allez non c'est si vous
si vous n'êtes pas capables de répondre
à l'interroger creed que je vous colle
au début montrant vous avez bien compris
ce qu'elle demande ou du coeur je vous
parle même pas je pense que si elle
faisait ça ça serait beaucoup plus fort
beau avec un pouvoir de pénétration
beaucoup plus important
la suggestion n'est pas brevetées donc
mais non je ne vais pas de revendication
a tu le sais juste pour dire que je
comprends très bien
l'expression de cette encore une fois de
cette angoisse la dérive vers laquelle
il faut pas que ces mouvements aille je
crois c'est de considérer qu'à partir du
moment où ils ont une expression
légitime sur j insiste sur légitime sur
le fait que le problème doit être traité
il se met à avoir des préconisations non
travailler sur les solutions à appliquer
parce que là ils vont se faire allumer
et devront dire des conneries ils vont
dire des conneries donc ils vont se
faire allumer parce que de même que ça a
pris 5 à 20 ans à la communauté
scientifique mondiale de bien comprendre
le problème ça prend n'importe quoi
entre 6 mois et 10 ans de travail est un
élément de solution en se demandant
quelle est sa place dans l'ensemble
quels sont ses avantages et ses
inconvénients les risques qu'il crée
risque est qu'il permet d'éviter donc on
est dans des systèmes complexes et
autant on peut demander on peut on peut
non seulement demandé mais écouté avec
attention des adolescents qui nous
disent c'est quoi ce bordel c'est pas
parce qu'un adolescent dit à son père tu
bois trop papa que nécessairement il a
la solution sur la façon de le faire
arrêter de boire
il se peut que ils connaissent pas
encore assez bien la vie pour avoir des
solutions qui soient activable à dire
qu'il peut avoir des envies mais c'est
pas nécessairement les modes donc je
pense que reste une minute
oui mais c'est juste pour dire que donc
le donc ces mouvements là je les invite
à rester centrée sur leur domaine de
pertinence qui se suffit viendra
lui-même qui est de dire les mecs pas
saisie du temps pour le moment vous êtes
une bande de feignants et on
al'impression vous en vous en foutez ça
c'est intolérable
donc pas saisie du temps montré que vous
intéresser à la question et que ça monte
haut sur votre agenda
avant même de savoir si vous allez faire
des vélos du nucléaire des cultures de
l'agro économie et s'est pas saisie du
temps au moins d'accord je pense que
cette demande là on peut rien lui
imposer
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
fort
à partir du moment où il commence à
vouloir s'inviter sur le terrain des
solutions et est-ce qu'il faut plutôt
des missiles des machins et les avions
enfin tous les trucs qu'on a passé en
revue il ya un vrai risque que ça dérape
parce que jamais ils auront le temps
pour accumuler les expertises
nécessaires sur tous ces trucs là pour
être pertinent sur tous ces trucs là on
devrait leur donner cette expertise là
un truc ça prend maintenant le faire ça
prend maintenant je veux dire moi ça m'a
pris un temps quoi alors malheureusement
il ya un train et un kit à temps et puis
du coup on va devoir s'arrêter là
j'espère que c'est que partie remise
en tout cas une page 1 finalement tuyaux
j'ai trouvé pas mal de questions c'est
un long sujet je suis très bavarde
accord qui revient en suisse en tout cas
tu est la bienvenue
c'était déjà un énorme cadeau que tu
nous as fait de mettre ton temps est à
disponibilité à notre disposition
merci infiniment merci pour cet accueil
et puis à bientôt et à bientôt ciao